écoutez nos échanges vont faire une
place à la présentation des efforts de
recherche pour améliorer cette
protection des circuits névralgiques et
c'est là un aspect essentiel de la
Sûreté Nucléaire tel du moins que nous
la concevons en France c'est-à-dire dans
une perspective dynamique avec un effort
permanent pour
l'améliorer c'est une question que j'ai
souvent l'occasion évoquer
euh en particulier avec des
interlocuteurs étrangers qui demandent
est-ce que la Sûreté Nucléaire vous êtes
vraiment dans une situation
optimale et ma réponse est toujours la
même à savoir que la sûreté nucléaire
est une matière vivante qui se nourrit
de la recherche en sûreté nucléaire et
qui se nourrit de la confrontation des
idées entre une autorité de sûreté un
appui technique scientifique
et le l'opérateur puisque c'est de cette
discussion que peut progresser la Sûreté
Nucléaire donc la sreté nucléaire c'est
tous les jours qu'elle se gagne c'est
pas un sommet qu'un jour on a atteint et
où on peut s'arrêter et contempler sa
centrale nucléaire en disant j'ai
atteint l'état de sûreté à la suivante
elle doit encore se gagner donc c'est
une c'est quelque chose qui est
permanent c'est quelque chose qui doit
s'améliorer en permanence et c'est
quelque chose qui est vivant au cours
des débats qui suivront les dans les
interventions les membres du Parlement
membres de la mission parlementaire
auront une priorité d'utilisation du
temps de
parole les membres des comités d'experts
puis les journalistes pourront poser des
questions je demande simplement à chacun
de ceux qui posera des questions de se
présenter puisque de tout cela il sera
établi un compte-rendu intégral et qui
sera publié les interventions été
regroupées en deux sessions présidées
chacune par un rapporteur la première
concerne l'analyse des mécanismes de
défense en profondeur présidé par le
Premier vice-président bruno Sido
sénateur la seconde présentera les
efforts de recherche pour améliorer la
production des circuits névralgique elle
sera présidée par Christian Bataille
chacune sera suivie d'une phase ouverte
aux questions auquel je pour laquelle je
représente je reprendrai la présidence
j'ai souhaité que lors de chacune des
auditions publiques au début l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire fasse un point sur
la situation à
Fukushima Monsieur Thomas oudr a déjà eu
l'occasion de faire un panorama général
de la situation jeudi dernier j'ai
proposé qu'il s'attache plus
spécifiquement aujourd'hui au problème
de la nature et de la portée des rejets
radioactifs ainsi qu'à la question
d'évaluation des populations dans la
zone à risque et ben je vais demander à
monsieur oudr d'être aussi précis et
clair qu'il l'a été la semaine
dernière merci monsieur le Président euh
euh enfin juste une phrase sur sur la
situation
technique telle qu'on la comprend à
Fukushima qui n'a pas évolué
sensiblement euh par rapport à l'exposé
que j'ai essayé de faire jeudi dernier
euh sur euh
la question que vous posez l'évaluation
des des rejets radioactifs et des
conséquences pour les
populations
euh donc c'est c'est un domaine sur
lequel la les connaissances donc l'
encore évolueent et s'affine au fil des
jours euh je signale notamment euh la
publication récente par l'IRSN
l'Institut de radio protection de sreté
nucléaire d'un rapport qui euh d'un
rapport à fait complet qui fait le bilan
justement sur ces aspectsl euh
l'évaluation des rejets et des
conséquences pour les populations donc
qui est disponible sur le site Internet
de de
l'IRSN ce rapport retrace notamment donc
pour la phase accidentelle donc vraiment
les les premiers jours suivant
l'accident les différentes évaluations
de dose qui ont été réalisées euh donc
ça soit par des organismes japonais ou
étrangers euh et prés présente un
certain nombre de cartes retraçant ces
évaluations le ce qui ce qu'il en
ressort c'est que les diverses
évaluations donc faites soit par des
Américains soit par des des Japonais
soit par
l'IRSN proposent des des résultats qui
sont
comparables et qui ne présentent pas de
de différences significatives qui
permettent notamment de confirmer le
fait que les mesures
d'évacuation prises par les les
autorités japonaises pendant les
premiers Monds la crise de de
Fukushima était des des actions de
protection des populations qui sont
considérées comme appropriées et
correctement dimensionné
euh le le rapport de de l'IRSN se se
projette également sur la phase de long
terme donc la l'exposition des
populations lié à l'exposition dans le
temps donc sur une longue durée euh du
fait notamment des dépôts
de particules radioactives de césium
notamment qui sont présentes en quantité
parfois évidemment importantes dans
l'environnement dans l'environnement
proche de de la centrale de Fukushima y
compris dans la zone allant au-delà de
km donc ce ce rapport fait un certain
nombre d'évaluation donc sur la base de
cartes qui sont qui figurent dans dans
le rapport et qui permettent d'évaluer
les les niveau dose euh qui serait reçu
par par les populations si elles av
étent maintenu sur
place euh on constate notamment que donc
si si les les les populations
qui qui peut peuvent encore être
présente à à l'extérieur de la zone
d'exclusion de 20 km il y aurait
sensiblement 2000 personnes qui
recevraient une dose supérieure à 100 m
CIV euh sur une année ce qui est qui est
une dose qui est qui est qui est
significative puisque la dose
d'exposition autorisée pour le public en
France est de 1
MIV il y a également des des projections
qui sont
faites sur une vie donc typiquement sur
ans qui là encore mett en évidence le
fait qu'un qu'un nombre
important de de personnes pourra être
concerné par des des doses lié à à
l'exposition du fait des dépôts
euh si elle n'était pas enfin si elles
étaient maintenues en place
euh donc tout cela
ensuite tout dépend évidemment des des
des mesures prises par les les autorités
japonais en matière d'évacuation ou de
euh ou de relocalisation des des
populations en
place merci
monsieur
rapporteur voilà et ben écoutez merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
notre première session de cette audition
est consacrée au mécanisme de défense en
profondeur c'est-à-dire aux différents
niveaux successifs de protection
permettant d'assurer l'intégrité du
réacteur même en cas de défaillance d'un
système lié au fonctionnement d'un des
circuits
névralgiques le but ultime est
d'ailleurs moins de préser le réacteur
lui-même que d'empêcher l'apparition
d'une configuration pouvant mettre les
produits radioactifs du cœur en contact
avec
l'environnement nos visites sur dans les
installations nucléaires à nojanssène
puis à Graveline et dernièrement à
flamandville nous ont déjà permis de
découvrir certains de ces dispositifs de
défense en profondeur notamment ceux
permettant d'assurer l'alimentation
électrique par des voies à la fois
différentes et redondantes ce qui permet
de garantir une capacité de pilotage en
dépit de pannes d'origine très diverse
nos intervenants vont avoir la pour
tâche de décrire les différents
dispositifs constitutifs du mécanisme de
défense en profondeur en mettant en
valeur comment cette défense se renforce
avec la prise en compte des retours
d'expérience notre premier intervenant
monsieur martial Jorel de l'IRSN va nous
expliquer comment la défense en
profondeur s'organise dans le cas de la
technologie des réacteurs à eau
pressurisé technologique qui équipe
l'ensemble du parc nucléaire français
ensuite monsieur George Servière
conseiller du président DDF passera de
la description des principes de la
défense en profondeur à la présentation
des dispositifs pratiques de production
pour les 58 réacteurs du parc nucléaire
français le réacteur pr qui repose comme
les 58 réacteurs français desjà en
service sur la technologie à haut
pressurisée a été conçu spécifiquement
pour progresser d'un cran dans la
sécurité des centrales notamment pour
répondre au dangers de fusion du cœur
illustré par les accidents de sumand et
Chernobyl Monsieur Bertrand Barret
conseiller scientifique d'Areva nous
expliquera donc l'apport complémentaire
des réacteurs nucléaires de 3e
génération en ce qui concerne la défense
en profondeur enfin Monsieur Thomas oudr
et Sébastien com de laasn vont nous
expliquer maintenant comment le contrôle
exercé par l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire pousse au renforcement
constant des mécanismes de protection
des réacteurs notamment à l'occasion des
visites
décenales alors Monsieur Jorel vous avez
la
parole bien merci Monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs j'ai prévu donc de
conformément à l'ordre du jour ma
présentation sera articulée sur défense
en profondeur dans les réacteurs à haut
pressurisé je vous ferai d'abord une
présentation de principe et puis chaque
ligne de défense sera commentée d'une
part du point de vue des avancées
réalisées et d'autre part des points
d'attention notamment vis-à-vis du
retour de l'accident du retour
d'expérience de l'accident de Fukushima
alors pour la facilité vous verrez dans
mes transparents il y a des zones vertes
pour les avancées et des zones oranges
pour les points d'attention donc mon
premier transparent euh vise à
présenter le rôle de l'IRSN voilà
l'Institut de radio de protection et de
sûreté nucléaire ce transparent est très
chargé mais je voulais juste vous faire
passer le message que pour faire une
analyse de risque réel d'une
installation il faut connaître tous les
risques potentiels et ces risques
potentiels il nécessitent de faire des
études de sûreté sur des sujets
difficile on voit par exemple les chutes
d'avion la thermohydraulique il
nécessite aussi de de faire de la
recherche afin de bien connaître les
phénomènes physiques lié au risque et
puis l'autre volet d'une d'une approche
réelle de l'analyse de risque c'est de
connaître l'état des installations
comment sont conçus les systèmes comment
ils sont exploités comment les matériels
sont sont entretenus comment sont
traités les anomalie et je crois que
c'est ce qui fait la force de l'Institut
c'est d'être finalement au cœur de tous
ces métiers et d'avoir les deux les deux
volets de la balance je dirais pour
effectivement porter un jugement sur les
risques réels de l'installation avec
effectivement des hypothèses comme vous
l'avez souligné monsieur le Président
que le contexte de sûreté évolue ainsi
que les les les
objectifs alors le transparent suivant
vous présente les lignes de défense
toutes les lignes de
défense c'est un résumé pour que je vais
essayer de vous commenter donc chaque
ligne de différentes couleurs la
première ligne de défense c'est
d'obtenir une installation fiable et
robuste ce sont les dispositions de
conception d'études et de réalisation
qui font que l'installation doit être
conçue et réalisée tel que prévu et donc
l'action à mener pour vérifier que tous
ces dispositifs sont effectivement
efficaces la vérification de la
conformité la deuxième ligne de défense
c'est une une une ligne de résistance de
l'installation face aux incidents qui
peuvent être des pertes de sources
électriques des défaillances de matériel
l'idée c'est que le réacteur doit rester
dans son domaine de fonctionnement
autorisé donc l'analyse de cette ligne
de défense passe par les enseignements
des incidents le retour d'expérience
c'est ce que je vous présenterai la
ligne suivante traite des accidents la
maîtrise du domaine du concept de
conception c'est-à-dire que dans le
principe de la défense en profondeur on
prend toutes les précautions à la
conception mais on imagine quand même
que cette conception est mauvaise ou
qu'il y a des des défaillances et donc
on on est on se base sur un C nombre
d'accidents hypothétiques qui vont de la
grosse brèche du primaire du circuit
primaire à la rupture d'une tuyauterie
vapeur et on met en place des systèmes
supplémentaires sur l'installation vous
le voyez dans le petit schéma à gauche
en bas il y a des systèmes à l'extérieur
du bâtiment réacteur qui apparaissent ce
sont des pompes qui alimentent le
circuit primaire en eau pour refroidir
le cœur en cas d'accident qui a contribu
à dépressuriser l'enceinte de
confinement aussi en cas d'accident Dans
dans l'enceinte et puis à droite on voit
des lignes d'arrivée d'eau sur les
générateurs de vapeur qui contribuent
aussi à refroidir les générateurs de
vapeur et donc le système ASG aussi
c'est un système d'appoint de secours en
situation accidentelle alors tous ces
systèmes sont redondants ils tiennent au
séisme dans les qure charges prévu euh
avec un point particulier ces systèmes
puisent de l'eau dans des réservoirs ou
des bâches qui sont en général uniques
hein on en voit une apparaître là la Bâ
du circuit d'injection de sécurité la
ligne de extrême à droite donc c'est la
ligne qui relative aux accident graves
alors oui sur cette dernière ligne
accident évidemment les efforts à Moné
ce sont des études études probabilistes
on n plus du tout dans le retour
d'expérience on est dans le domaine des
études probabilistes de prévention de la
fusion du cœur dernière ligne de défense
à droite c'est la ligne relative aux
accidents graves c'est une ligne qui a
été mis en place suite à l'accident de
TMI puisqueavant on n'imaginait pas
finalement ces accidents graves s les
installations donc là on touche le
domaine de la Red sur les accidents
graves le domaine des études et la mise
en place de dispositifs ou de
compléments de justification sur les
installation puisque finalement le point
important c'est quand même l'état de
l'installation donc je je vous ferai
part de de de C de ce qui a été fait sur
les installations à ce
sujet transparent suivant donc comme je
vous disais j'ai commenté ligne par
ligne c'est la première ligne
installation fiable et robuste alors ces
deux messages qui sont en vert je crois
que le point important c'est que l'IRSN
j' dirais a toujours
défendu l'idée qu'il fallait faire des
vérifications de conformité sur les
installations notamment sur les systèmes
passifs et je dirais il y a une dizaine
d'années on a mis en évidence des
insuffisances de tenue au séisme des
bâes des systèmes de sauvegarde qui ont
été corrigés et je crois que c'est
quelque chose qu' vaut garder en tête
une installation robuste doit faire
l'objet de vérification de conformité je
vous parle du séisme mais on peut aussi
parler des inondations et de tout ce qui
est protection contre les aggressions
deuxiè message c'est la disponibilité
des systèmes de sûreté alors c'est un
message qui paraît tout à fait banal euh
EDF engage un grand programme d'essais
périodique sur les installations des
requalifications des matériels des
traitements d'écart il est important de
ne pas régresser si vous regardez sur
Internet vous voyez que par exemple l'an
dernier il y a eu un incident aux
États-Unis il y avait trois défauts
latant depuis 2 ans et ça c'est ça a
dégénéré en accident je dirais très
embêtant pour la chaudière avec le plan
d'urgence deux incendies donc c'est des
choses sur lesquelles il faut demeurer
vigilant euh ligne de défense suivante
c'est effectivement la partie incident
donc là les moyens d'analyse ce sont les
le retour d'expérience qu'est-ce qu'on
craint par rapport à l'analyse
d'incidence c'est ce que j'ai mis sur le
petit schéma haut à droite c'est
finalement les incidents précurseurs ce
sont des des incidents qui dégénèent et
qui peuvent passer en accident grave
sans même avoir eu une ligne de défense
effective au niveau de l'accident alors
j'ai cité par exemple des incidents qui
sont arrivés en 2001 à manchan à Taiwan
perte totale des sources électriques
pendant 2h force Mar on en a beaucoup
parlé tous ces incidents ont commun une
idée principale c'est qu'un un réacteur
peut-être agressé par son réseau
électrique par des par des parasites ou
des surtensions ils ont été analysés
aussi bien par EDF que par l'IRSN en
tant que précurseur et je crois que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut garder en
tête aussi et je dirais l'éclairage de
voie de progrès par rapport à cette
ligne de défense c'est effectivement de
maintenir ces analyses d'incidents
précurseurs mais c'est aussi peut-être
de se poser la question des précurseurs
en terme d'agression parce
qu'effectivement je crois qu'on n'est
pas assez attentif aux incidents qui
touchent des agressions qui se
produisent à l'étranger à transpor sur
nos installations il y a eu suffisamment
de tsunami de tornades de choses comme
ça je pense qu'il faut analyser ça en se
en se mettant en tête est-ce que ces
incidents peuvent dégénérer donc dans ce
cadre d'irsn a demandé à F de regarder
la problématique lié aux tornades dans
le cadre du réexamen des 3oè décennales
des réacteur 1300
MW le point suivant c'est toutes les
études d'accident alors je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure d'accident hypothétique
de grosse brèche je voulais signaler que
dans les années 70 l'IRSN EDF avait fait
des études de fiabilité de système qui
montrait que bah la principale faiblesse
des systèmes redondants étaient les
modes communs et on avait découvert que
la probabilité de perdre ces systèmes
redondant était de l'ordre de 10-5 par
réacteur et par an ce qui était jugé
important au vu des conséquences si vous
perdez des systèmes redondants vous
alleer à la fusion du cœur donc dès les
années 80 ces situations ont été étudié
perte totale de la source froide perte
totale des alimentations électrique
perte totale de l'eau alimentaire des
procédures ont été mises en place et je
voulais juste signaler que en 2000 9 on
a eu une perte totale de la source
froide àruas qui est arrivée au bout de
1500 années réacteurs un peu plus tôt
que prévu et qui a quand même fortement
valoriser ces dispositions je crois
qu'il faut avoir en tête que ces
dispositions ont été des lignes de
défense effectives et je pense qu'à la
lumière de fouushima il faut les
réexaminer en se reposant la question du
retour d'expérience des durées de
mission des exigences mais il y a quand
même des réflexions encore une fois ce
sont les études qui ont fait avancer la
sûreté deuxiè volet en bas du
transparent qui qui est très raccourci
il faut savoir que autant l'IRSN queedf
au sein d'irsn et EDF des EPS des études
probabilistes de sûreté sont menées
vis-à-vis de la prévention de la fusion
du cœur il y a eu beaucoup d'avancées
sur vis-à-vis de ces études sur des
sujets difficiles notamment les risques
dans les états d'arrêt qui étaient des
risques majeurs au niveau risque horaire
dans les années 90 les risques de
dilution qui ont été mis en évidence
suite à l'accident de Tchernobyl ces
études ont permet de permis de mettre à
place ses risques de les quantifier et
de définir des mesures correctives
efficaces
donc on pense que ces études
probabilistes doivent être déclinés
alors s'il y a des projets actuellement
ça ça se construit mais il fauttivement
continuer ces études probulises dans le
domaine des agressions séisme inondation
et incendie aussi puisque c'est une
agression interne qui qui est qui est
important alors ce transparent il traite
des accidents graves là aussi
euh en haut du transparent vous voyez
toutes les études qui ont été mené
finalement la RD monsieur Micheli vous
en parlera il y a très rapidement
finalement des études qui ont été
lancées au moment de du rapport rmounsen
en 75 avant Thami l'IPSN à l'époque
avait déjà lancé des études et elles ont
débouché sur des modifications
effectives alors il y en a trois qui
sont cité en bleu la première
modification consiste à fiabiliser les
soupables du circuit primaire pour
dépressuriser le réacteur afin d'éviter
la fusion en pression c'est ce que fait
les opérateurs à Fukushima il est
important en cas de perte de
refroidissement de dépressuriser donc
c'est une modification importante la
deuxième modification c'est la mise en
place d'un filtre à sable pour pouvoir
contrôler les rejets en cas d'accident
avant la rupture de l'enceinte et ça
c'est le un filtre qui s'appelle le
filtre U5 on a parlé aussi à Fukushima
et on a bien vu l'importance de ces
rejets s'ils ne sont pas filtrés et puis
autre modification qui est en place
aussi sur tous les réacteurs c'est la
mise en place de recombineurs
d'hydrogène pour éviter les risques
d'explosion d'hydrogène suite à l' à
l'oxydation des gaines du combustible
ces modifications sont en place depuis
plusieurs années alors les avancées
aujourd'hui c'est la mise en place de
l'étude probabiliste vis-à-vis des
accidents graves qui a été misise en
œuvre dans les réexamens des trè
visitees décennal 900 MW qui abouti sur
trois modifications importante
renforcement de la boulonnerie du tampon
d'accès matériel pour avoir une
meilleure tenue de l'enceinte de
confinement implantation de mesures
d'hydrogène et puis détection de percer
de la cuve et vous et ces modifications
sont actuellement réalisées à Fessenheim
et à Tricastin et vous avez vu dans
l'actualité de Fukushima que on se
posait beaucoup de questions
effectivement avait-on ou non percé
cette cuve euh ce qu'on peut dire donc
dans dans dans toutes ces cette démarche
accident grave par contre il y a
probablement des réflexions à mener sur
les quatre charges pour les matériels en
accident grave par exemple le filtre 5
ne tient pas au séisme on n pas
aujourd'hui de connexion entre les
accidents graves et les agressions donc
il y a un certain d'exence à revoir en
terme de de de de durée de mission de
tenue aux agressions d'indépendance sur
les sur les accidents graves autre volet
à voir ce sont les conditions
d'intervention en situation ultime sur
une santé centrale nucléaire comment
amener des moyens mobiles et surtout
comment les connecter au systèmes qui
sont en général défiabilisés c'est ce
qu' c'est la question qui a posé
Fukushima alors deux derniers points sur
les agressions les inondations c'est pas
sous l'approche 4 charge c'est pour vous
montrer que en fait suite à l'incident
de Blayet l'inondation a été traitée en
terme de cas de charge ça vous a été
présenté mais il y a eu aussi une
approche événementielle qui a été
discutter entre l'IRSN et EDF qui
consiste à regarder qu'est-ce qui peut
se passer sur un site sous is à
inondation et perte de sources externes
et cette approche a amené à à renforcer
l'autonomie des systèmes par des
réserves d'eau par des réserves de
fioule et par la fiabilisation des
groupes électrogènes alors là aussi on
peut penser que c'est un impact
important vis-à-vis de Fukushima il y a
probablement à revoir ses lignes de
défens les durées et les types de cumul
vis-à-vis de ce sujet dernier sujet le
séisme on vous a parlé de séisme en tant
que qu charge ce transparent vous montre
que le séisme aussi a été regardé sous
d'autres aspects par exemple séisme
événement quel est l'impact d'un séisme
euh sur des matériels qui ne tiennent
pas au séisme qui sont dégradés et qui
chutent sur des matériels qui tiennent
au séisme donc là vous avez deux
exemples un portique près d'un bâtiment
réacteur qui peut chuter sur un groupe
électrogène et une salle des machines
EDF a fait des études pour vérifier
qu'en cas de séisme la salle des
machines ne risquait pas d'agresser le
bâtiment électrique qui est juste à côté
et puis deuxième point sur le
l'agression sismique il a eu des efforts
aussi de de de meilleures évaluations
par des codes de calcul qui ont amené à
des renforcements plancher ça a été le
cas à fessenim et où des
requalifications de matériel sur le
palier N4 des matériels électriques ont
été requalifiés parce que les planchers
avaient des mouvements non prévus au
départ et je conclurai sur le petit
transparent vert qui vous fait état donc
des études EPS sismiques les études
March sismiques qui ont été réalisés à
Tricastin d'une EPS sismique qui est en
cours à Saint-Alban qui sera regardé
dans le cadre des troisè visites
décennales 1300 MW et donc tout ça ça
rejoint bien l'idée effectivement de de
de développer ces études probabilistes
agress j'en ai terminé
merci merci Monsieur
Jorel maintenant je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur George Servier qui est
conseiller du président def et donc qui
va nous
passer la description des principes de
défense en profondeur vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président en
fait c'est Jean-Marc mirour qui va faire
la présentation pour le compte desdf
donc je lu passe la parole tout de
suite merci donc j'ai quelques par en
fait ma ma présentation va globalement
comporter trois parties elle va
consister à à vous donner les les
principes de conception des systèmes de
protection dans une deuxième partie je
vous dirai comment ils sont dimensionnés
et dans une troisième partie comment est
évalué leur robustesse et que peuton que
peut-on dire de de cette robustesse donc
sur le merci beaucoup c'est là ok si on
peut passer sur le transparent suivant
donc les principes de conception
c'est là que j'appuie voilà ah je aller
trop vite voilà donc en fait les
principes de conception repose sur une
une démarche
systématique comme je je vous l'avais
exposé pour les les é naturels on
commence par recenser les fonctions de
sûreté assuré et la maîtrise de ces
fonctions de sûreté assure la protection
de l'homme et de l'environnement contre
les effets des accidents et on arrive
sur nos nos installations à trois
fonctions de sûreté principales la
maîtrise de la réaction nucléaire
l'évacu de la puissance en
fonctionnement normal en fonctionnement
accidental bien sûr et le confinement de
la radioactivité et donc le principe est
simple pour dimensionner les systèmes de
de protection et bien on adopte la
stratégie de défense en profondeur de
ces trois fonctions de sûreté et on
cumule des lignes de défense qui peuvent
être multiples successives diversifié
pour garant garantir la maîtrise de ces
fonctions alors à quel stade ces
systèmes de protection sont-ils conçus
ou modifiés bien sûr ils sont conçu dès
le début de la de la conception initiale
des centrales qui et cette conception se
concrétise par l'autorisation de
création et l'autorisation de mise en
service de de l'installation mais tout
aussi important ces systèmes de
protection sont revisité requestionné à
chaque réexamen de sûreté donc là on
arrive dans la le concept d'amélioration
continue de de la sûreté donc c'est au
travers des réexamens de sûreté en
particulier les réxamens de sûreté
décennaux que euh sont réexaminé les la
robustesse de ces systèmes de protection
et ça peut se traduire par des
modifications des installations en
particulier il y a trois sources de
réexamen de sûreté évidemment la prise
en compte du retour d'expérience
nationale et internationale en
particulier celui des accidents la
deuxième source est l'amélioration des
connaissances scientifiques avec en
particulier la progression des moyens de
calcul et des modélisation numérique des
installations et de leur comportement et
la troisième source c'est l'augmentation
des exigences de sûreté en
général alors maintenant je vais vous
dire comment sont dimensionnés ces
systèmes de de protection et en quoi il
consiste en fait il y a trois types de
lignes de défense en profondeur il y a
des dispositifs de protection passif je
vais vous en donner quelques exemples il
y a des dispositifs de protection
automatique actif automatique qui se
déclench automatiquement et il y a des
dispositifs de protection actifs qui
sont mis en œuvre par les par les
opérateurs je vais vous donner le le
principe de ces trois lignes de défense
alors premier exemple donc de dispositif
de protection passif c'est évidemment le
principe de conception autour des trois
barrières interposées successivement
entre la radioactivité c'est-à-dire le
combustible qui se situe dans le cœur du
réacteur et l'extérieur de la centrale
et donc vous avez sur ce schéma les
trois barrières de confinement la
première barrière ce sont les gaines qui
entourent le combustible au centre du
cœur de la cuve la deè barrière c'est le
circuit primaire lui-même dans lequel
circule l'eau qui refroidit le
combustible et la troisième barrière
c'est l'enceinte de
confinement un Notat important que que
je voulais vous signaler c'est que donc
le le parc français est est un réacteur
de type standardisé autour de la filière
de la technologie haut pressurisée PWR
en anglais et ce qui est important c'est
de de voir que la la la vapeur qui sort
de l'enceinte de confinement qui sort en
haut à droite de l'appareil qui est
nommé générateur de vapeur n'est pas
radioactive et c'est donc de la vapeur
non radioactive qui va vers la turbine
contrairement à la technologie BWR de
Fukushima réacteur à eau bouillante où
c'est l'eau qui a directement circulé
dans le cœur qui sort de l'enceinte de
confinement qui est donc radioactive et
qui va actionner la turbine donc on peut
dire que nous avons sur cette
technologie PWR une ligne de défense
supplémentaire toujours des exemples de
dispositifs de protection passif c'est
la con tion elle-même du cœur du
réacteur où nous avons un cœur autost
stable c'est-à-dire que s'il y avait une
excursion de puissance pour une
quelconque raison du cœur et bien cette
augmentation de puissance provoque une
élévation de la température qui
elle-même étouffe la puissance nucléaire
donc nous avons un principe
d'autostabilité un noté important c'est
évidemment un un principe qui ne
figurait pas sur le réacteur de
Tchernobyl où le cœur s'autoemballit en
cas d'augmentation de la puissance donc
c'est évidemment un dispositif de
conception passive très important sur
nos réacteurs un troisième exemple de
disposition passive c'est l'arrêt de les
réactions nucléaires en en particulier
en cas de perte d'alimentation
électrique où il y a il y a chute des
barres par leur propre poids par gravité
dans le cœur pour arrêt de la réaction
nucléaire puis j'ai donné un autre
exemple il y en aurait d'autres
d'injection d'autre sécurité dans le
cœur ce sont des réservoirs sous
pression gonflés sous pression qui
envoient de de même l'eau dans le
circuit primaire dans le cœur en cas de
chute de pression dans le cœur deuxième
type de dispositif de protection ce sont
les dispositifs actifs donc des pompes
des des générateurs et autres qui
interviennent de façon automatique alors
pourquoi de façon automatique puisqu'il
concerne toutes les actions qui sont
requises à court terme pour atteindre un
état contrôlé des fonctions de sûreté et
donc là on prend comme postulat
raisonnable je pense que l'homme
n'aurait pas le temps d'agir donc là ce
sont les automatismes qui agissent
quelques exemples l'arrêt automatique de
la réaction nucléaire en cas d'incident
des sououspables de sécurité l'injection
d'eau de secours dans le circuit du cœur
du réacteur l'injection d'eau de secours
dans le générateur de vapeur l'aspersion
de l'enceinte et également important
démarrage des générateurs d de secours
qui par exemple sur une rupture complète
du circuit du cœur du réacteur démarre
en 10 secondes on imagine bien que dans
ce pour avoir ce type de réaction seuls
les automatismes permettre d'y faire
face enfin le la dernière ligne type de
dernier type de de système de protection
ce sont les dispositifs de protection
actif qui sont mis en œuvre par les
opérateurs donc là on entre dans toutes
les actions requises pour un un
atteindre un état sûr des fonctions de
sûreté dans la durée donc là on est sur
plusieurs heures plusieurs jours après
l'accident la première tâche des
opérateurs c'est de contrôler que tous
les systèmes automatiques sont bien
rentrés en service puis de d'engager les
actions à long terme partant de l'État
contrôlé atteint de façon automatique
les opérateurs regagnent un état sû par
refroidissement du réacteur
dépressurisation du réacteur contrôle de
la concentration c'est-à-dire de la
réactivité et cetera donc l'ensemble de
ces actions évidemment n'est pas
improvisé ils font l'objet de
procédurees de conduite accidentelle
auxquels les opérateurs sont formés et
rompus grâce en particulier au fait que
nous ayons un simulateur pleine échelle
par site je crois que vous avez eu
l'occasion en particulier de de de de de
vos visites et de vos auditions sur les
sites de voir de tels
simulateurs alors alors maintenant
quelques principes de de conception qui
qui démontrre la robustesse des systèmes
de protection en fait il y a trois type
de robust enfin la robustesse des
systèmes de protection repose sur trois
types de mesures des mesures de
redondance on multiplie des systèmes
identiques des mesures de
diversification pour assurer une même
fonction de sûreté on on met en place
des systèmes différents et le tout
reposant sur une une vérification
périodique fréquente de de leur bon
fonctionnement pour rejoindre en
particul un élément qui était mis en
avant tout à l'heure par l'IRSN je vais
détailler chacune de ces lignes le
principe de redondance quelques exemples
les actions automatiques de protection
du cœur à court terme sont cadruplé dans
le contrôle commande les systèmes de
sauvegarde injection de sécurité les
dieles de secours les circuits
d'aspirion auxiliaire les circuits de
refroidissement des piscines de stockage
du combustible sont doublés euh chacun
d'eux pouvant assurer la fonction à lui
seul la fonction requise j'ai mis sur ce
transparent un nota qui concerne la
présentation suivante sur le Pr partant
d'une nouvelle conception on a encore
accru le niveau de redondance mais ça
fera l'objet de de la présentation de
d'Areva
deuxè élément de robustesse la
diversification pour une même fonction
de sûreté on peut mettre en place
plusieurs systèmes complètement
différents donc là j'ai donné l'exemple
des moyens de secours électrique il y a
il y a cinq moyens de secours électrique
différents dont en particulier les les
diesel de secours qui sont protégés
contre le séisme et les inondations une
seule de ces cinq alimentations
suffisant pour garantir le
fonctionnement de matériel de sûreté
j'ai un deuxième exemple de
diversification pour refroidir le cœur
via les générateurs de vapeur on peut
avoir des pompes qui fonctionnent de
façon électrique mais nous avons aussi
des pompes des turbopompes qui
fonctionnent grâce à la vapeur produite
elle-même par les générateur de vapeur
ce qui est un système qui ne requiert
pas d'alimentation électrique de
puissance externe
et puis donc dernier élément de
robustesse c'est la vérification en
permanence du bon fonctionnement des
systèmes de protection ce sont les
essais périodiques en fait en
fonctionnement normal les opérateurs
passent leur temps à vérifier par des
essais périodique le bon fonctionnement
des systèmes de sauvegarde plus de 2000
2000 essais pardon par réacteur et par
an qui sont destinés à vérifier cette
opérationnalité la fréquence des essais
est adaptée à la nature et l'importance
de la fonction pour les fonctions les
plus importantes ce sont quelques jours
qui séparent des essai périodiques et
évidemment dès qu'un essai périodique au
cas où un essai périodique révèle
l'indisponibilité d'un système de
protection d'un système de protection il
peut y avoir pour les plus importants
d'entre eux arrêt du réacteur par
exemple les systèmes de protection qui
assure la protection du cœur à court
terme en cas d'indisponibilité révélée
par un essai périodique entraîne l'arrêt
du réacteur sous une heure pour
réparation ma dernière la dernière
partie de ma présentation va s'attacher
au dimensionnement de ces systèmes de
protection en fait on fait on fait feu
de tout bois pour dimensionner ces
systèmes de protection la base du
dimensionnement c'est une démarche
déterministe c'est on postule des
défaillances les plus graves et on
vérifie on met en place les systèm de
protection pour éviter la fusion du cœur
on complète cette démarche déterministe
par une vérification probabiliste et on
vérifie par une démarche probabiliste
exhaustive qu'on n'est pas passé à côté
de situations importantes pour la sûreté
et ensuite on complète tout ça par une
ligne de défense ultime on suppose
malgré tout ça malgré ces deux lignes de
défense qu'un accident grave peut se
produire et on met en place une ligne de
défense ultime pour faire face à de
telles
situations la démarche déterministe en
quelques mots et bien pour chaque
fonction de sûreté par exemple la
maîtrise de la réaction nucléaire on
suppose la défaillance du système ou des
systèmes qui assurent la première ligne
de défense de manière à mettre en place
des lignes de défense supplémentaires
pour pallier la défaillance de cette
première ligne de
défense un exemple si je prends la
fonction de sûreté évacuation de
puissance cette évacuation de puissance
comme vous l'avez vu à Fukushima repose
sur le nom dénoyage du cœur du réacteur
et bien on suppose la rupture totale et
instantanée du circuit primaire c'est du
circuit qui renferme l'eau du réacteur
cela entraîne la vidange du cœur du
réacteur pratiquement instantané et donc
on met en place des systèmes de
protection systèmes d'injection de
sécurité Système de démerrage de diesel
de secours qui sont destinés à renoyer
le cœur avant atteindre des critères de
sûreté la deuxième démarche qui vient en
complément c'est la démarche
probabiliste donc on vérifie de façon
probabiliste que le niveau de sûreté est
suffisant donc on recense tous les
systèmes qui jouent un rôle de sûreté on
quantifie leur fiabilité on met tout ça
bout à bout et on arrive à une
probabilité du risque à une
quantification du risque résiduel de
fusion du cœur et donc ça il cela permet
de vérifier que on n rien oublié dans la
démarche probabiliste et ça permet en
particulier d'orienter les Ramin de
sûreté vers des sujets qui auraient pu
échapper à la démarche
déterministe donc un un exemple de de la
robustesse donc le risque de fusion du
cœur est actuellement quantifié sur les
réacteurs français à des valeurs
inférieures aux objectifs fixés par
laiaa sur le plan international ces
objectifs pour les réacteurs en
exploitation sont de moins d'un risque
sur 100000 ans suite à des défaillances
internes de de matériel interne à la
centrale faut rappeler que les rxamin de
sûreté on ont on ont résulté en une
division par 10 de ce risque environ
depuis leur conception initiale sur les
réacteur français et la deuxème le
deuxième objectif fixé par la IEA c'est
moins d'un risque tous les 10000 ans
suite à un risque naturel
externe et en ligne de défense ultime
nous mettons en place les moyens de
maîtrise des conséquences des accidents
graves l'objectif étant d'éviter des re
des rejets radioactifs entraînant des
conséquences importantes pour les
population en cas de fusion du cœur donc
là ce sont des exemples que nous vous
avons déjà donné lors des auditions
précédentes par exemple la mise en place
de recombineurs d'hydrogène passif qui
ont été mis en place sur tous nos
réacteurs pour éviter le risque
d'explosion dans l'enceinte de
confinement dû à l'hydrogène qui serait
produit par la dégradation du cœur en
cas d'accident grave l'autre exemple que
nous avons déjà cité lors des auditions
c'est la mise en place de de filtres
vous voyez ce ces gros appareils qui
sont des filtres dans lesquels il y a du
sable spécial qui retient le sésium en
particulier en cas de nécessité de
décomprimer l'enceinte de confinement et
vous aurez bien noté que c'est le césium
qui pose un problème de contamination au
Japon pour terminer euh évidemment suite
à l'accident de Fukushima nous allons
réexaminer l'ensemble de ces lignes de
défense conformément au cahier des
charges qui a fait l'objet de la
décision de l'Autorité de sûreté du 5
mai dernier donc nous allons réexaminer
la protection contre les aléas les
parades contre les défaillance de ces
systè des systèmes même s'ils sont
protégés contre ces aléas c'est nous
allons aller voir au-delà de de des
lignes de défense actuelles et en 3oème
ligne de défense nous allons réexaminer
toutes les mesures en place tous les
moyens en place pour limiter les
conséquences d'accidents graves quel
qu'en soit la cause tout ceci s le
contrôle de de l'Autorité de sûreté pour
terminer et ce sera mon dernier
transparent donc quels sont les les les
atouts procurés par ces systèmes de
protection sur la sûreté du parc
français donc vous vous l'aurez compris
une conception initiale réacteur à haau
pressciurisé largement répandu et
présentant une bonne robustesse intrinsè
en particulier au travers des des trois
lignes de défense une amélioration
continue de la sûreté au fil des ré
examens de sûreté exploitant le retour
national et mondial car comme vous
l'avez indiqué Monsieur le Président il
n'y a pas de bonne sûreté si elle ne
progresse pas au fil du temps et au fil
de la des connaissances le troisième
grand atout c'est un parc standardisé
qui permet une mise à niveau de tous les
réacteurs du parc aucun de nos 58
réacteurs n'échappe aux mesures de
d'amélioration de la sûreté mise en
place suite au examen de
sûreté une formation des opérateurs de
haut niveau grâce en particulier à un
simulateur de pleine échelle par site à
plusieurs semaines de formation continue
par année pour chacun pour chaque pour
chaque opérateur et ce qu'il y a
derrière tout ça c'est une organisation
industrielle qui intègre une ered forte
mais également qui s'appuie sur la
recherche et développement faite par
l'IRSN par le CEA et également au plan
international l'intégra l'intégration
également au sein deedf d'une ingénierie
et de moyens d'exploitation qui
permettent une maîtrise continue de la
conception des centrales tout au long de
leur cycle de vie merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur mir cours donc
merci EDF nous passons au point 3 qui me
paraît très
important c'est nous allons donner la
parole à Monsieur Bertrand barré
conseiller scientifique de l'endroit qui
va nous expliquer l'apport
complémentaire des réacteurs nucléaires
de 3e génération puisquon nous a dit et
redit qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus sûr
en ce qui concerne la défense en
profondeur monsieur Barret vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le
Président donc ainsi que vous indiqué la
3e génération a été conçue après
tchernoby donc en prenant en compte des
exigences assez supérieur en terme de
sûreté et notamment la prise en compte
dès le départ des accidents les plus
graves donc dès la conception il y a eu
trois grands thèmes d'abord réduire la
probabilité d'un accident grave au
niveau de la prévention en prenant en
compte à ce moment-là comme
déclenchement les événements internes
des agressions internes et des
agressions
externes puis bien sûr
ensuite la réduction de l'impact sur les
populations en cas d'accident grave donc
accidents grave on entend par là avec
fusion du cœur et pour ça je vous
décrirai un peu les systèmes dédiés qui
ont été rajoutés pour la génération 3 à
des réacteurs qui par ailleurs sont dans
une grande continuité technologique avec
les 58 réacteurs qui son actuellement en
exploitation et puis mais je
n'insisterai pas énormément dessus
puisqu'on a dit que le terrorisme ne
faisait pas partie de l'affaire mais
quand même renforcer la capacité de
résistance aux agressions externes donc
notamment avec la prise en compte d'une
chute d'avion commerciale et pas
uniquement de l'aviation légère qui
était prise en compte dans les
générations précédente donc au niveau de
la prise en de la réduction de
probabilité et bien les principes sont
les mêmes c'est-à-dire redondance et
diversité des systèmes et des
équipements mais je vous indiquerai ce
qui a été poussé un peu plus loin dans
dans ce cadrel
et notamment le fait que cette
redondance qui était déjà fonctionnel
dans une certaine mesure a aussi été
rajouté géographiquement pour éviter des
modes communs venant d'une
agression sur ce qui est de la
protection contre les
accidents graves je vais décrire un peu
dans le détail le principe de ce qu'on
appelle le récupérateur de corium qui
est quelque chose de très
nouveau un peu caractéristique de cette
génération 3 et en ce qui concerne la
protection contre les chutes d'avion
vous verrez que dans le Pr il y a en
plus des protections habituelles des
coque antiuc d'avion qui protège une
partie des systèmes de sauvegarde et le
bâtiment combustible
donc si on envent au circuits de
sauvegarde principaux ils sont cette
fois-ci d'une redondance 4 c'est-à-dire
4 x 100 % il y a qu trains de sûreté qui
ont chacun la capacité à lui tout seul
de assurer la protection et la fonction
de sûreté pour le réacteur et ces quatre
trains sont et c'est une nouveauté
installés dans quatre bâtiments séparés
de façon justement à prendre compte une
agression qui ne pourrait pas en mettre
hors service plusieurs à la fois alors
qu'ils sont supposer se porter
assistance donc protection qui n'est
plus uniquement fonctionnelle redondance
uniquement fonctionnelle mais avec
séparation géographique pour prévention
contre les modes commun cha chacune de
ces divisions est alimenté bien sr par
les systèm d'alimentation norm mais
aussi par un diesel principal
et puis pour ajouter de la redondance et
aussi de la diversification de des
trains de sauvegarde sont peuvent être
alimentés par deux dieséseles
différentes d'une technologie différente
pour en assurer la pour en assurer la la
diversité ce qu'on appelle les diesel
SBO ce qui est l'acronyme de station
blackout c'est-à-dire perte totale des
alimentations électrique de la centrale
donc vous avez quatre diesels principaux
et aussi de diesels suppl
aire alors un
exemple de protection euh oui je me suis
un peu emmêlé mes pinceaux moi
pardon donc les événements qui internes
qui sont pris en compte perte de
réfrigération primaire perte des
alimentations électriques externe
c'est-à-dire classiquement ce qui est
intervenu à Fukushima si vous vous
voulez il y a la la prévention
d'éléments avec défaillanceces multiples
donc perte de réfrigération primaire
avec défaillance de injection de
sécurité perd des alimentations
électriques externes avec défaillance
des diesels principaux et là vous avez
les deux petits Dieselles
supplémentaires que j'ai mentionné sont
pris en compte également bien
sûr l'incendie et l'inondation qui sont
des agressions internes qui touchent
énormément de système à la fois dans les
ression externe séisme chute d'avion et
perte de la source froide et alors bien
sûr les accidents grave c'est la prise
en compte de la fusion et compris de la
fusion totale du cœur du réacteur avec
limitation
importante des conséquences à
l'extérieur donc les circuits de
sauvegarde principaux je suis désolé
c'est ce que je vous avais dit il y a 2
minutes parce que je m'étais trompé dans
l'ordre de mes diapositives
et un exemple de défense en profondeur
et bien en cas de défaillance du réseau
électrique principal vous avez toute une
série de mesures possibles le le plus
simple si on réussit à le faire c'est
l'ilotage c'està-dire l'autoalimentation
de la tranche par son propre
turboalternateur on peut aussi si on n
arrive pas à avoir l'arrêt avec
démarrage automatique des qu diesels de
secours
si on a perdu le réseau
principal proche de la centrale par
exemple par des problèmes de la
sousstation on peut se basculer sur un
réseau auxiliaire qui lui est n'est plus
à 400 kV mais à 110 kV qui est branché
plus loin et qui permettrait à ce
moment-là aussi de faire un repli sûr et
puis si effectivement même les dieseles
de secours refusent de démarrer et bien
on a la possibilité de faire app à ces
deux diesel dit SBO pour l'alimentation
de la tranche en repli et un seul
dieszel SBO serait encore suffisant pour
maintenir la tranche en arrêt
sûr sur cette vue d'ensemble vous voyez
la séparation des
quatre
trains des divisions des trains de
sauvegarde donc vous voyez que il y en a
deux qui sont contigus qui sont
présentés ici sur le bas euh de la du
dessin de droite ces deux euh trains
contigus font l'objet d'une protection
supplémentaire par coq
anti-avion et les deux autres trains eux
n'ont pas cette protection
supplémentaire mais étant disposé de
part et d'autrre du bâtiment réacteur
euh il n'y a pas euh d'agression
crédiible qui les mettrait hors service
tous les deux à la fois et vous voyez
que la coque est aussi rajouté sur le
bâtiment combustible qui donc cette
fois-ci a une protection très supérieure
à celle qui était des réacteurs des
génération
précédente donc il protège cette coque
les agressions externes incendie
inondation rupture de tuyauterie et bien
sûr aussi les agressions externes
derrière la conception de l'pr il y
avait très fortement cette prise en
compte des agressions externes et et je
crois que on peut reconnaître que
c'était un apport important des
Allemands puisque vous savez que le Pr
était au départ une conception
franco-allemande vous avez là en ce qui
concerne les bâtiment diesel de
secours ce qui vous montre que
d'abord les bâtiments qui qui reçoivent
les deux deux diesel de secours et un
diesel SBO sont des bâtiments rés ant
solide avec des portes qui sont
résistantes également aux
surpressions et
donc bien sûr c'est son on en parlera à
la fin ce sont des des agressions qui
sont en cours de de réexamen pour les
stress test mais dès le départ c'était
des diesels qui étaient bien
protégés là aussi on a joué sur la
diversification géographique
c'est-à-dire que ces six diesels sont en
dans deux divisions différentes de part
et d'autres du bâtiment réacteur là
encore pour
éviter la crédibilité d'une agression
qui les mettrait en service tous à la
fois et vous voyez que à l'intérieur de
d'un de ces compartiments vous avez les
deux
diesels normaux de et puis ce fameux
petit diesel SBO qui peut alimenter donc
une un des trains de
sauvegarde en ce qui concerne la
protection contre les choutes d'avion et
donc on a pris en compte non plus
seulement l'aviation légère non plus
seulement l'aviation militaire mais
aussi le le crash d'un d'un avion
commercial et c'est pour ça donc qu'on a
rajouté cette fameuse coque anti-avion
résistante dont l'épaisseur est
équivalente à la deuxème enceinte du
bâtiment réacteur et donc qui recouvre
les deux trains contigus de sauvegarde
et le bâtiment comb
en ce qui concerne le bâtiment réacteur
donc cette enceinte externe résisterait
à l'impact y compris d'un d'un avion
commercial d' d'un gros porteur normal
et le choc sur l'enceinte externe ne se
répercute pratiquement pas sur
l'enceinte interne puisque elles ont un
grand espace entre les deux et ne sont
rejointes si je peux dire que par le
radier
les bâtiments combustibles et les deux
qui sont protégés bien ont la même paroi
externe donc il il résistent au même
type de choc et c'est pareil ils sont
ils sont découplés de des bâtiments
internes là encore la coque externe
permet ce découplage avec l'espace qui
est entre les deux et quant au bâtiments
qui ne sont pas protégé et bien c'est
eux comme je l'ai déjà dit qui sont
séparés physiquement et c'est cette
protection qui fait que la mise hors
service simultanée de deux d'entre eux n
apparaît très peu probable donc si on en
perd un et bien ça n remet pas en cause
la protection de l'ensemble puisque je
vous rappelle que ils sont quatre et que
chacun d'eux a 100 % de
capacité vous avez sur ce schéma donc
cette illustration de la protection
contre les chutes d'avion donc le
bâtiment réacteur avec avec ces deux
enceintes et vous voyez que elle se
poursuit à gauche pour protéger le
bâtiment combustible et donc à droite
pour protéger une des sections de de
sauvegarde donc deux d'entre elles ont
cette protection
supplémentaire en ce qui concerne la
protection du public contre les
accidents graves là si on va jusque au
bout et que par une séquence que l'on ne
cherche pas à déterminer on arrive à la
fusion du cœur et bien on a un système
de récupération du corium c'est-à-dire
que on admet que le cœur fondu peut
sortir de la cuve à ce moment-là il
serait passivement étalé dans une zone
réfractaire qui est prévu à cet effet et
qui serait dans un premier temps aussi
passivement refroidi en utilisant l'eau
du grand réservoir interne au
confinement mivement parce que ce
réservoir est à une altitude plus élevée
que la zone de récupérateur du
corium au passage l'eau circulerait
d'abord entre les dalles réfractaires du
récupérateur de corium et le radier pour
protéger le béton du radier et ensuite
par déversement viendrait effectivement
renoyer le cœur fondu étalé et le
solidifier à plus long terme bien sûr il
faudrait passer à un système
pour évacuer la chaleur par mise en
service du système d'aspersion mais déjà
le les premières actions sont
passives deuxièmement pour toujours
limiter les rejets dans l'environnement
il y a cette double enceinte du réacteur
l'enceinte interne ayant en plus une
peau d'étanchéité et comme depuis les la
série des 1300 les fuites éventuelles
entre les deux enceintes par des
faiblesses des des traversées par
exemple sont reprises et passerai sur
fil TR àable pour empêcher
effectivement des rejets massifs de
particules de césium et enfin dès le
départ d le début de la conception de le
Pr une cinquantaine de recombineurs
passifs sont répartis dans le bâtiment
réacteur pour assurer dans chacun des
sous-compartiments en quelque sorte que
l'hydrogène brûlerait avant d'atteindre
une une concentration qui lui
permettrait la
déflagration donc en cas d'accident
grave avec traversée de la cuve ce
corium irait s'étaler dans une zone qui
est sèche jusque là cette zone ce
récupérateur de corium est couvert ceci
dans le but d'éviter les risques
d'explosion vapeur quand
c'est l'eau qui se déverse sur le corium
on n' pas ce risque et on évite une
situation où ce serait le corium qui
coulerait dans de l'eau ça ne veut pas
dire que ça déclencherait
automatiquement une explosion vapeur
mais c'est un risque qu'on qu'on évite
en étant sec jusqu'à l'arrivée du cœur
fondu deuxièmement le risque d'explosion
hydrogène j'en ai parlé on a parlé
également de la double enceinte ce qui
fait que avec tout cela même en cas de
fusion du cœur il y a pas besoin
d'évacuer les populations à
proximité ça c'est quand même assez
important et même ce qui est un critère
presque un peu plus difficile à à
à à à à
satisfaire on ne condamnerait pas plus
de une récolte si on avait cet accident
absolument maximum qui est fusion
complète du cœur donc vous voyez que
sans même chercher à déterminer la
probabilité de cet accident
maximum il est prévu que s'il se produis
ça ne soit pas une catastrophe pour
l'environnement et on n'est pas
d'évacuation massive à faire ce qui fait
quand même une différence assez
considérable par rapport à ce qu'on est
en train de connaître au
Japon alors là c'était juste pour
rappeler donc que Fukushima nous
soulève peut-être quelque chose qui
n'avait pas été pris en compte
suffisamment c'est-à-dire le cumulle la
conjon
d'événements exceptionnel et donc c'est
pour cela que à l'heure
actuelle nous nous sommes lancés à Areva
et bien sûr en coopération très étroite
avec EDF dans le le réexamen de en
suivant les stress tests tels que
définis par WENRA et plus précisément
donc la lettre de l'ASN qui date du 5
mai c'est donc une évaluation qui est
encore en cours mais il est clair que
parmi les choses qu'on qu'on va étudier
c'est la survie éventuelle des diesels
si il y a inondation jusqu'à une
certaine hauteur de la plateforme
l'étanchéité des portes et cetera
l'accès à la source froide bien que si
il y a une forte inondation il puisse y
avoir obstruction par un nombre
important de débris ce qu'on a vu se
passer au
Japon et
donc ce processus est en
et tant que je veux dire on ne l'a pas
encore discuté avec les autorités de
sûreté et leur appuis technique on on ne
donne pas encore de résultats qui serait
prématuré à cet état je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Barret nous
allons maintenant écouter Monsieur
Thomas oudr et Sébastien combr de l'ASN
qui vont nous expliquer comment le
contrôle exercé par l'autorité de sûrté
nucléaire pousse au renforcement
constant des mécanismes de protection
tion de réacteur vous avez la parole
monsoud
merci
je juste attendre que les transparents
arrivent
voilà donc
euh vous vous voyez enfin sur ce
transparent le résumé des des actions de
laasn donc dédié à améliorer sans cesse
à pousser les opérateurs à améliorer
sans cesse le niveau de sûreté de leurs
installations c'est valable pour les
centrales nucléaires de DF ça serait
valable pour les autres installations
nucléaires exploitées par Areva ou le
CEA euh par exemple pour l'essentiel de
celle-ci
euh donc cinq cinq grands points sur
lequel je vais je vais revenir
l'instruction des dossiers déposés par
EDF les inspections l'analyse des des
événements ou des incidents qui se
produitent indisent le contrôle des
opérations qui se déroulent lors des
arrêts de réacteur pour les réacteurs
nucléaires de DF et les réexamens de
sûreté associé aux visites
décennales donc il faut savoir que
effectivement chaque modification d'une
centrale
nucléaire susceptible d'avoir un impact
sur la sûreté du réacteur doit faire
l'objet d'une déclaration avec un
ensemble d'éléments justificatifs par
EDF à l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
cette déclaration euh est analysée euh
par l'ASN donc avec le concours de de
l'IRSN euh pour évaluer l'impact sur la
sûreté de celle-ci euh et laasn donc
prend position donc soit de manière
positive soit positive avec réserve soit
éventuellement euh le rejet de de la
déclaration euh de modification lorsque
il y a des des des enjeux de sûreté euh
ou des régressions de sûrté qui qui sont
envisagées j'ai j'ai j'ai la ce sont des
dossiers donc qui concernent
potentiellement l'ensemble des des
aspects affectant la sûreté euh et donc
évidemment tous les dispositifs de
protection j'ai cité quelques exemples
euh sur ce slide euh faut savoir qu' il
y a un flux extrêmement important de de
telles modifications euh qui sont
examinées chaque
année
euh évidemment donc un une des missions
primordiales de de l'ASN c'est euh de de
vérifier
euh donc que au cours du temps euh
l'organisation de DF permet d'assurer la
conformité de l'installation aux
exigences euh éventuellement modifié
donc notamment au travers des des
modification que je viens de euh
d'évoquer euh donc pour ça
euh on s'appuie sur les les inspecction
effectué par l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire donc à peu près un un millier
d'inspections tous les ans sur les
installations nucléaires euh qui couvre
l'ensemble des stades euh de la de la
vie d'une installation nucléaire donc de
depuis la conception jusqu'au
démantellement euh de de l'installation
euh avec évidemment les opérations de
fabrication ou de construction qui sont
qui sont concernés notamment pour les
équipements sensibles euh des réacteurs
les équipements sous pression nucléaire
donc la cuve euh les tuyauteries euh les
générateurs de vapeur tout ça fait
l'objet d'un programme d'inspection
spécifique euh qui est détaillé après
euh
dans ce sont des des inspections donc
qui font l'objet systématiquement d'une
lettre de suite qui est publiée sur le
site internet de la SN donc à laquelle
tout à chacun peut avoir accès euh qui
peuvent également donner lieu à des
mesures coercitive en cas de besoin
lorsque l'exploitant ne se plie pas aux
demandes de l'ASN ou lorsqu'il y a un
enjeu de sûreté extrêmement important
oui donc le renforcement des le
renforcement donc des dispositifs de
contrôle concerne également la
fabrication avec donc depuis depuis
depuis quelques années donc
l'établissement d'un nouveau cadre
réglementaire donc qui assure désormais
des règles homogènes du contrôle de
l'ensemble des équipements sous pression
dit nucléaire c'est-à-dire qui
contiennent un niveau significatif
d'activité donc laasn donc est fortement
impliqué dans ce contrôle de la
fabrication des équipements sous
pression nucléaire euh ces inspections
se font effectivement chez dans les
ateliers des fabricants donc avec des
actions de terrain également donc chez
les sous-traitants avec des chaînes de
sous-traitance qui sont relativement
importantes il s'agit aussi de faire des
examens documentaires car effectivement
il y a forcément un lien entre la
qualité documentaire des éléments
apportés et puis la qualité de
réalisation pour ces pour ces activitésl
la SN s'appuie nécessairement comp tenu
du volume important donc de la
fabrication sur des organismes qu'elle
agrée et qu'elle supervise également
alors le contrôle fait par laasn
concerne à la fois donc le volet de la
conception donc euh ça a été dit tout à
l'heure donc par Marcel Jorel la
conception c'est un des piliers aussi du
système de défense en profondeur il faut
que les équipements soient bien conçu
donc cette conception se base sur la
prise en compte des chargements et d aux
agressions qui trouvent donc leur
fondement et leur établissement dans le
rapport de sûreté donc c'est le lien
entre la sûreté et la conception des
équipements sous pression qu' se qui se
fait ainsi la conception doit également
prendre en compte le retour d'expérience
on a cité tout à l'heure quelques cas
euh où effectivement le retour
d'expérience même en France montre
qu'effectivement des des chargements ne
sont pas correctement pris en compte je
pourrais citer par exemple en 98 à civau
donc des zones de mélange non identifié
à la conception qui on induit donc des
phénomènes de filuration par fatigue
thermique relativement rapidement donc
c'est cette prise en compte du retour
d'expérience qu'il est nécessaire de de
prendre en compte il a également aussi
cette le retour d'expérience il se prend
en compte sur l'évolution des matériaux
la diminution de la fragilisation de la
cuve et là aussi on peut compter sur les
apports et les avancé fait au niveau des
des forgerons avec notamment les
techniques donc d'affinage qui
permettent d'avoir des des aciers
beaucoup plus purs avec des niveaux donc
d'impureté relativement réduit qui
permettent donc de de de réduire
justement la la
température de la température de
fragilisation alors ce contrôle donc ça
concerne la conception et ça concerne
donc je l'ai dit tout à l'heure les
opérations de fabrication notamment les
opérations les plus importantes qui sont
les soudages qui génèent encore malgré
la
malgré le le retour d'expérience de la
fabrication qui génère encore pas mal de
pas mal de défaut donc dont il est
nécessaire de de s'assurer donc avec des
contrôles réguliers que ces opérations
sont faites sans dérive de de
réalisation donc on a une vérification
approfondie des équipements au niveau de
la fabrication pour leur apporter le
niveau de garantie de qualité nécessaire
à cet usage
nucléaire donc sans rentrer forcément
dans dans le détail de de l'ensemble des
des autres thématiques qui sont évaluées
périodiquement par l'autorité de sûrté
nucléaire au travers des des inspection
donc vous avez un aperçu qui qui est pas
exhaustif qui qui vous permet
de d'apprécier la la diversité des des
thématiques qui sont périodiquement
évaluées au cours des au cours des
inspections euh donc notamment au cours
du suivi en
service des des réacteurs nucléaires
donc on a
parlé du processus de de retour
d'expérience donc qui est notamment
encadré par l'obligation qui est faite
aux opérateurs donc DF au premier chef
en France de déclarer l'ensemble des
événements significatifs donc l'ensemble
des
écarts qui sont détecté sur son
installation cette enfin ces incidents
sont systématiquement euh examiné par
par l'autorité de sûrté nucléaire par
les inspecteurs euh avec l'appui de de
l'IRSN euh font l'objet également donc
l'ensemble du retour d'expérience lié à
l'exploitation fait fait l'objet de
présentation régulière donc au groupe
permanent d'experts qui est placé auprès
de laasn et qui appuie euh laasn pour la
prise de ces décisions majeures donc
c'est bien l'illustration de de
l'importance qu'on accorde à à cette
thématique et évidemment donc toutes ces
instructions font se traduisent euh par
des demandes qui sont adressées aux
opérateurs concernés donc à EDF
notamment qui qui est tenu de de mettre
en œuvre euh un un exemple donc qui
permet aussi d'illustrer que euh ce
retour d'expérience ne se limite pas
uniquement euh aux événements qui se
produisent en France mais intègre bien
euh également euh les les événements qui
se produisent au niveau international
euh donc c'est euh la problématique
du risque de colmatage des puisards
euh donc des puisards qui sont en fait
utilisés en cas de rupture d'une d'une
partie du circuit primaire dans dans un
tel type d'accident donc on aurait une
quantité importante d'eau qui
s'échappera du circuit primaire qui euh
serait se retrouverait dans dans le
bâtiment enfin dans dans l'enceinte de
confinement et dont ensuite il est prévu
qu'elle soit collectée donc par des
puuisards de manière à ce que c puisse à
nouveau être injecté euh donc par
l'objet de de circuit prévu à cet effet
euh au sein du cœur du réacteur pour
maintenir le refroidissement du
combustible
nucléaire donc euh on s'est aperçu
notamment sur la base du du retour
d'expérience internationale et et euh
enfin spécifiquement venant de Suède euh
d'une euh d'une problématique d'un
risque de colmatage de ces puisards lié
en fait au au débris donc les les
puisards qui sont
qui figure en bas de de cette
diapositive qui peuvent donc en cas d'un
d'un tel accident être obstrué par les
les débris qui seraient occasionnés donc
par au niveau de la brèche
euh donc l'autorité de sreté nucléaire
avec l'appui de de l'IRSN à la suite de
de ce ce retour d'expérience
international demander à EDF d'étudier
le phénomène pour ce qui concerne ses
installations euh ce qui a conduit en
fait à EDF à ne pas être en mesure
d'exclure d'exclure ce risque sur ces
centrale et ce qui conduit en fait à une
revue complète de la la conception de
cette fonction de recirculation qui est
actuellement en
cours donc la SN comme je le disais
intervient également sur le contrôle des
arrêts de de réacteurs puisque ce sont
des des opérations sensible dans la
mesure où il y a une quantité importante
d'opérations de maintenance qui sont
réalisé elle intervient avant l'arrêt
par l'examen du programme prévisionnel
des opérations de maintenance par
exemple elle intervient au cours de
l'arrêt au travers du suivi des
contrôles et des travaux qui sont
réalisés en réalisant également des
inspections de chantier spécifiques ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que donc
l'ensemble de ces des redémarrages des
réacteurs est soumis à l'autorisation de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire euh qui
n'est évidemment pas délivré s'il
reste un point qui n'est pas
satisfaisant donc j'ai j'ai là cité
enfin ça peut être des choses qui
conduisent à des des prolongations
significatives j'ai des durées d'arrêt
j'ai j'ai cité l'exemple du réacteur de
budget 3 qui du fait d'un d'un problème
affectant un équipement sous pression a
été maintenu à l'arrêt sur la période
d'avril 2009 à janvier
s
excusez-moi oui pour illustrer également
donc un point un point majeur donc de du
rôle de l'ASN et aussi de la
responsabilité qu'elle engage dans dans
le contrôle il y a donc les les visites
décinal avec donc la requalification
complète du circuit primaire principal
donc à l'issue de de cette
requalification l'ASN délivre un procès
verbal donc cela effectivement atteste
donc l'engagement qu'elle prend pour la
remise en service de à cette occasion du
du circuit primaire donc ce cette cette
requalification complète du circuit
primaire donc a lieu lors des visites
décennales donc c'est un un rendez-vous
tout particulier où effectivement donc
est réalisé un test de résistance du du
circuit primaire et en amont de celui-ci
la réalisation donc de contrôle
approfondis sur sur l'état de la
chaudière donc le contrôle approfondi ça
relève à la fois donc des contrôles euh
engagés par l'exploitant sous sa
responsabilité mais complété aussi à la
demande de l'ASN euh par des des
contrôles supplémentaires qui résulte
effectivement d'une démarche en
profondeur il est important donc que ces
contrôles supplémentaires ne tiennent
pas compte des des des des barrières
précédentes de la de de la du principe
de défense en profondeur mais soit
effectivement indépendant de manière à à
ne pas uniquement contrôler les zones où
on suspecte des défauts mais également
celles où priori les risques ne sont pas
identifiés mais pour autant on on n'est
pas à l'abri d'avoir des mauvaises
surprises il y a eu par exemple en 2000
2006 donc le colmattage des générateurs
de vapeur qui ne faisait pas donc
l'objet les les plaques entretoises ne
faisaient pas l'objet de contrôle
approfondi et ce colmattage a généré
donc sur Cruas une fissure
circonférentielle qui a conduit à une
fuite primaire secondaire très
importante donc c'est important à cette
occasion qu'effectivement l'accent soit
mis sur des contrôles approfondis pour
avoir un état le plus complet possible
de de la chaudière
euh ce cette visite décennale elle
contribue également à l'assurance de la
maîtrise du vieillissement puisqu'il y a
aussi une attention toute particulière
qui est portée sur la cuve qui fait
l'objet d'un d'un contrôle périodique
donc tous les 10 ans avec l'examen donc
de l'ensemble de des viroles de la cuve
et des défauts de fabrication
susceptible donc d'être détecté et à
cette occasion donc euh un examen
complet de la justification de la tenue
des cuves pour les 10 ans à venir est
fait donc la visite décennale c'est à la
fois une signature pour une remise en
service de la chaudière mais également
c'est une une position par rapport à la
poursuite d'exploitation sur les 10 ans
à venir concernant la tenue en service
des
cuves et je concluraai la présentation
en indiquant donc les les vises descenal
en fait elles s'inscrivent dans le cadre
plus large des des réexamens de sûreté
donc on deux grands objectifs euh c'est
d'abord de vérifier la conformité de
l'installation par rapport aux règles
qui lui sont applicables et deuxièmement
de réévaluer l'appréciation des risques
euh que présente l'installation regarde
des des nouvelles connaissances qui sont
qui sont disponibles euh et c'est en
fait donc sur la base de ces deux
éléments qui sont très clairement
associé aux visites descénal que laasn
est amené à se prononcer sur l'aptitude
euh du réacteur à poursuivre son
exploitation éventuellement sous réserve
de prise en compte d' certain nombre de
prescriptions techniques qui viennent
renforcer les exigences applicables au
réacteur
j'en ai fini merci monsieur oudr nous en
venons à la phase de questions et de
réponse moi je vais lancer je vois
monsieur Cochet qui va poser une
question tout de suite après moi moi
j'ai deux questions la première pour EDF
à un moment dans votre présentation
monsieur mirocour vous avez dit qu'il
s'agissait d'augmentation la conc tion
en bord pour l'injection dans la cuve
mais il me semble pas que vous ayez
précisé auparavant quel était le rôle du
bord donc ça c'est la première question
la deuxième question pour l'autorité de
surreté
nucléaire la confrontation des idées au
lors des réunions du groupes des groupes
permanents est-ce que c'est une
spécificité française ou bien est-ce que
dans d'autres pays puisque des experts
étrangers participent au groupes
permanents en France est-ce que cette
procédure des groupes permanents existe
à l'étranger
et pour avoir assister comme témoins
muet il y a dans les années début des
années 90 à des réunions de groupes
permanents je puis vous dire que ce qui
à l'époque s'appelait le des
c'est-à-dire le département d'études de
sûreté de
l'IRSN jouait le rôle du procureur
EDF était dans le rôle de
la la défense et l'ASN était le juge et
ça se passait comme ça et à la fin de la
journée ben on récapitulait tout ce qui
restait à faire à
EDF pour faire ses démonstrations de
sûreté et on se donnait rendez-vous 15
jours ou 3 semaines plus tard et le
pauvre gars DDF repartait la tête basse
épuisé par tant de sollicitations et par
l'idée qu'il lui fallait encore répondre
15 jours plus tard à toutes les
questions qui avaient été posées par les
experts donc vous répondez à ces deux
questions et puis ben Bruno encore qui
joint à une question et puis ensuite on
passera au débat G
une question très simple le chantier de
flamandville 3 avance peut-être moins
vite que qu'en Chine mais avance
régulièrement et et ma donc le chantier
est très contrôlé et ma question est
toute simple c'est est-ce que l'ASN
l'IRSN ont une compétence en matière
d'architecture compétence spécifique
j'entends bien pour suivre ces grand ce
grand
chantier voilà grosso modo c'est
j'aimerais bien que vous me répondiez
sur ce point bon vous réponde vous allez
faire de la peine à à EDF puisque puis
peut-être encore plus au fabricants de
béton qui a dû démolir le béton parce
que on avait oublié quelques
ferraillements alors qui répond monsieur
mirocour d'abord puis monsieur oudr oui
très rapidement en ce qui concerne la
question sur le bord toujours dans avec
ce principe de diversification des
protections nous avons plusieurs moyens
pour contrôler la puissance nucléaire et
en particulier contrôler la production
des des neutrons dans le cœur parce que
c'est ce qui produit la puissance donc
je vous ai cité les barres de contrôle
un deuxième qui tombe automatiquement
dans le cœur un deuxième moyen et
l'injection d'un produit chimique qui
est qui est le bord dans l'eau puisque
le bord a la propriété d'absorber les
neutrons donc c'est un moyen en en
mettant du bord dans l'eau primaire de
contrôler la réaction nucléaire et en
particulier dans toutes les phases où on
veut qu'il n'y ait pas réaction
nucléaire c'estàdire maintenir le
réacteur à l'arrêt c'est un moyen de
contrôler euh la le non redémarrage de
garantir le non redémarrage de la
réaction nucléaire ce que nous appelons
la la non atteinte de la criticité dans
notre
chargon merci je crois que c'était une
précision utile monsieur oudr pour les
autres questions donc sur les les
groupes permanents euh ce ce n'est pas
une spécialité française il y a d'autres
pays dans lequel des institutions
similaires existe notamment aux
États-Unis notamment en Allemagne je je
suis pas du tout sûr d'avoir avoir une
vision exhaustive de des pays qui sont
dotés d'instances de ce typeel peut-être
l'OCDE
pourra-t-elle préciser mais c'est c'est
pas une spécialité française
euh et et en tout cas enfin clairement
l'ASN valorise et estime que c'est
quelque chose de de très souhaitable
d'avoir ce type de groupe permanent
d'experts qui permettent d'avoir des
points de vue euh enfin une instance de
discussion une instance de débat et des
points de vue qui sortent du cadre
strict des dialogue ASN IRSN euh EDF
pour ce qui concerne les réacteurs
nucléaires euh la question de la
compétence sur le réacteur enfin de de
laasn sur le réacteur de de flamandville
3 bah enfin je crois que clairement au
même titre que c'était enfin c'était un
challenge pour
F la question
du enfin de de le fait de 15 ans après
en gros la fin de de la du dernier
chantier de construction d'un réacteur
euh ça a aussi été un challenge pour
l'autorité de sreté nucléaire que de
retrouver les compétences euh en matière
de contrôle de la construction euh d'un
réacteur nucléaire avec effectivement
des spécificités sur les le contrôle des
opérations de génie civil euh le
contrôle des des opérations de montage
mécanique de de montage électrique
euh c'est clairement des des choses qui
font l'objet enfin que qui ont fait
l'objet de de formations spécifique pour
les inspecteurs de de
l'ASN et pour compléter cette réponse on
peut aussi dire que l'ASN avant même la
phase de donc de fabrication de montage
donc a examiner les choix de
conception de LEPR et notamment de
certains éléments qui étaient suivant
donc la terminologie de l'époque
utilisée un réacteur évolutionnaire donc
notamment avec une virolport tubulure
qui apportait une avancée technologique
et donc on la SN donc s'est positionnée
sur sur ce choix de
conception merci Monsieur Cochet euh oui
oui juste un complément de réponse là
sur les inspections génie civil je
voulais rappeler que le l'IRSN
intervient en tant que accompagnateur de
ces inspections il aide laasn à les
préparer et dans nos équipe nous avons
des spécialistes de génie civil qui ont
construit des bâtiments réacteurs qui
savent très bien ce dont il s'agit et
effectivement on a porté une attention
particulière à la qualité de
construction du réacteur op ce qui s'est
traduit peut-être par certaines probl
certains problèmes euh de de découverte
d'anomalie mais je pense que c'est un
sujet où on a beaucoup évolué et on a
même des guides d'inspection on sait
quels sont les point clés à examiner et
à quel
moment merci Monsieur cocher
oui merci monsieur le Président alors il
y a eu beaucoup de propos on peut dire
d'ingénieur très intéressant euh je n'ai
pas tout saisi hein je j'avoue bien que
je m'intéresse à ce sujet depuis un
certain temps mais par par exemple j'ai
vu sur une des diapos de
l'ASN il est indiqué brièvement on
examine les cuves et de manière sérieuse
alors je voudrais savoir quel est quels
sont les moyens supplémentaires par
rapport à ceux de l'exploitant que vous
avez pour examiner les cuves les fuites
éventuelles les défaillances les les
petites fissures que n'aurait pas
l'exploitant lui-même et donc en quoi
votre propre examen des cuves euh est
plus sérieux plus plus fort et est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire de
plus que ce que peut vous dire
l'exploitant qui lui-même a déjà sans
doute des moyens tout à fait
considérable pour examiner ces cubes
d'ailleurs euh une question subsidiaire
serait quel type d'examen est-ce que
c'est un examen évidemment direct ou
bien indirect par des des des capteurs
des des appareils de mesure que
c'estisje bon alors ça c'est une
première question euh deuxème question
euh est-ce qu'il n'y a pas même pour
même pour
laasn dans la mesure où il y a pas mal
de secret industriel quand même enfin
dans dans dans ces affairesl une sorte
de contradiction parfois entre aller
voir tout puisque pour vous rien ne doit
être caché tout est
susceptible de d'incident d'accidents
voire d'accidents graves et et puis le
fait que de manière publique vous dites
on envoie des lettres qui sont sur le
site de l'ASN le fait que à Reva ou
disent bah non écoutez là vous posez des
questions qui sont en fait qui
ressortent du secret industriel et donc
je ne pourrais pas vous répondre aussi
publiquement que ça c'est'est-ce qu'il y
a pas de manière on peut dire
intrinsèque non non pas une limite à vos
ex vos examens mais au moins une limite
à la à la manière publique de répondre
de la part de hareva ou de EDF dans la
mesure où il s'agirait de savoir s'il y
a des choses qui ne doivent pas être
dévoilées à l'extérieur euh et
d'ailleurs euh je c'est une troisème
question euh qui qui est du même ordre
d'idée euh la France prendre un concept
très général a dit nous on se distingue
des autres euh du débat européen
puisqu'il va y avoir un audit européen
avec le commissaire lui-même qui a une
vision évidemment il va avoir le plus de
pouvoirs possible mais les États-membres
disent non c'est nous on a nos propres
méthodes nos propres autorités de sûreté
mais il n'empêche que euh on peut se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi euh
il n'y aurait pas une vision européenne
une normalisation européenne et que ça
soit à peu près al vous allez me dire
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
réacteurs j'entends bien encore que les
PWR il y en a pas qu'en France et bien
pourquoi il n'y aait pas une sorte alors
il y a des stress test européens mais il
semble que le débat même entre
ingénieurs même entre autorités euh
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord autrement
dit vous laasn pour dire et bien euh on
doit se mettre d'accord entre autorités
de sûreté pour que ça soit les les mêmes
tests euh extrêmement fouillés complets
et cetera euh sur tous les réacteurs
européens ou bien est-ce que chacun fait
ce qu'il veut ce qui est un petit peu
ennuyeux parce qu'on voit que par
exemple nos nos amis allemands bon qui
sont en général des bons ingénieurs
aussi hein des gens très sérieux dans
tous les domaines et notamment dans le
nucléire et bien semble plus sourcilleux
euh par exemple éventuellement de fermer
certaines vies centrales s'intéresse au
vieillissement plus que nous enfin alors
est-ce que c'est plutôt que du point de
vue des ingénieurs eux-mêmes il peut y
avoir des différences d'appréciation sur
les tests de de sûreté ou bien vous
allez dire c'est pas à nous de répondre
c'est plutôt politique là c'est
différance d'appréciation politique
selon le gouvernement de tel ou tel pays
euh
alors 4è question si on veut bon vous
avez évoqué même si 'était pas prévu
notamment dans la lettre du Premier
ministre à laasn du mois de mars pas
prévu d'aller au-delà disons des aléas
naturels ben il y a des aluas des aléas
humain alors externe comme vous dites
hein par exemple les chutes d'avion
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est Monsieur
Barret qui a dit mais avec la génération
3 on on est beaucoup plus sûr même des
gros porteurs
éventuellement est-ce que là aussi il y
a il y a pas des choses qu'on a oublié
bon vous avez évoqué le terrorisme là
aussi le gouvernement français dit on ne
veut pas dire comment on
publiquement en tout cas mais est-ce que
vous ASN vous savez comment
disons dirais-je vous avez les garantie
de la part des opérateurs ou des
constructeurs que il y a certaine
sécurité cette fois-ci des installations
nucléaire de base vis-à-vis du
terrorisme c'est peut-être pas connu du
grand public vousz peut-être bras bras
de le dire parce que le gouvernement ne
veut pas mais moi je serais rassuré si
vous me disiez je ne peux pas le dire
mais je le sais quand même euh parce que
ça existe ce risque là ou bien alors al
on n'est pas dans un monde réel le
risque terroriste on nous en parle tous
les jours avec Monsieur guand il existe
même contre les installations nucléaires
donc est-ce que vous le savez vous
pouvez pas le dire ou bien alors qu'il y
a rien là-dessus enfin il y a une chose
qui n'a pas été évoquée dans aucun
transparent c'est très curieux c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la défection des
personnels alors on a vu ça dans
d'autres circonstances qui ne sont pas
directement lié au nucléaire c'est au
moment de Caterina la nouvelle-orléand
et cetera lorsqueil y a un événement
alors totalement extérieur qui ne vient
pas d'une défaillance on peut dire
technique par exemple d'une installation
nucléaire de base mais que un événement
je ne sais pas une greffe générale que
sais-je encore et bien est-ce que le
fait que les personnels puissent ne pas
le personnel intérieur à une
installation nucléaire de base ne
remplissent pas leur fonction qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans une centrale est-ce
qu'elle s'arrête toute seule parce que
tous les automatismes sont tels que là
on est sûr qu'il se passe rien ou bien
est-ce que si une centrale n'était pas
surveillée pendant 1 he 1 jour une
semaine 1 mois euh il pourrait y avoir
quelque chose qui relève de la sûreté
elle-même euh puisque c'est simplement
le fait que les gens s'en occupent pas
du tout parce que il y aurait je sais
pas une une épidémie générale les gens
veulent pas veulent pas se lever euh le
matin pour aller bosser que sais-je
est-ce que ceci est pris en compte dans
vos études de
sûreté merci on pourrait compléter euh
la question de Monsieur Cochet sur
l'intégrité des cuves par l'intégrité
des couvercles de cuves et ça nous
ramène à Davis B n'est-ce pas au aux
États-Unis et puis peut-être qu'on
pourrait juste rappeler aussi avec
Christian dans le cadre d'une étude sur
le vieillissement des centrales
nucléaires
nous étions allés en Allemagne et les
responsables de la
sûreté nous avaient dit
que comme le programme politique avait
été engagé entre le chancelier Schroder
et et sa
majorité qui avait pas d'étude sur le
vieillissement et que pour les
vieillissements il prenait en compte les
incidents les plus fréquents qui étaient
intervenus au cours des 20 premières
années auquel cas ma remarque mais
l'Autorité de sûreté pourra peut-être le
confirmer était que en général
l'arthrose et les douleurs ne
survenaient pas dans les 20 premières
années de la vie mais que c'était
beaucoup plus tard
je voudrais
profiter aussi du fait que j'ai la
parole pour saluer une délégation de
magistrats qui occupe les places qui
sont réservé à la presse magistrats qui
sont en stage à l'Assemblée
nationale donc je vais je vais apporter
donc les réponses pour la première
question donc en essayant d'être bref
puisqueeffectivement il il y en a il y
en a d'autres qui suivent euh donc en en
deux points euh la donc savoir
effectivement quels sont les moyens mis
en œuvre par l'ASN pour exercer en
totale indépendance finalement le le
contrôle des cuves et se positionner par
rapport à leur à leur durée de vie euh
alors euh sur le premier point rappelez
qu'effectivement la réglementation est
basée sur le principe que l'exploitant
est le premier responsable bon euh ça
c'est c'est c'est un c'est un fait
maintenant c'est un fait qui est en
cadré par une réglementation qui impose
quand même des exigences relativement
précises en la matière à savoir
qu'effectivement pour cette
démonstration l'exploitant est tenu
d'apporter la démonstration
l'exhaustivité des situations qui prend
en compte pour les études il est tenu de
procéder au contrôle de ces défauts avec
des avec des procédés qui sont qualifiés
donc qui passe devant une commission de
qualification qui prononce donc des
performanceces de des défauts des
performances pardon de contrôle
vis-à-vis des défauts crains il est tenu
de mettre en œuvre un un programme de
suivi de l'irradiation et enfin il est
tenu aussi dans ces démonstrations
mécaniques de d'intégrer des
coefficients de sécurité réglementaire
donc c'est un cadre réglementaire qui
effectivement donc permet de bien
encadrer les les démonstrations que
doivent apporter l'exploitant mais
effectivement ces démonstrations ce sont
bien les les exploitants qui qui les
apportent ça c'est le premier point le
second point donc de la réponse c'est de
dire aussi que laasn avec l'IRSN en tant
qu'appu technique examine donc les
démonstrations qui sont apportées avec
euh avec un certain recul notamment en
utilisant donc aussi des moyens des
moyens de calcul qui permettent de
considérer d'examiner et d'identifier
les transitoires qui sont susceptibles
d'être les plus nocifs vis-à-vis du
risque de surpression à froid qui est
encore une fois le le enfin l'événement
qu'on peut craindre pour la cuve et et
ça c'est c'est c'est c'est fait en avec
une forme d'indépendance par rapport au
choix que fait l'exploitant et ces
élémentsl justement sont pter dans le
débat en groupe en groupe
permanent parce que ce sont des éléments
qui effectivement peuvent aller affirmer
des positions prises par
l'exploitant juste petit àotac oui
c'estàd qu'en fait vous n'avez pas de
moyen supplémentaire c'est
l'autocontrôle de l'exploitant dont vous
examinez les rapports les plus détaillés
vous des papiers mais vous n'avez pas
vous-même évidemment des moyens de
contrôle supplémentaires ou différent de
ce de l'exploitant c'est les papiers que
vous
examinez la loi rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'exploitant est responsable de la
sûreté de ses
installations alors je voudrais quand
même préciser un point ça a été dit dans
la
présentation lors des visites décenales
a lieu l'épreuve hydraulique du circuit
primaire principal c'est une c'est une
épreuve qui engage la responsabilité de
la SN puisque les SC établit un procès
verbal à l'issue de celui-ci de celle-ci
et à cette occasion ça permet de faire
le lien avec ce que vous évoqueiez tout
à l'heure c'est lors d'une épreuve
hydraulique donc à buget en 91 qu'ont
été détecté les dégradations des des
traversées des couvercles de
cuve
pardon excusez-moi oui oui effectivement
l'épreuve hydrolic c'est donc dépasser
la pression de conception d'un facteur
de 1,2 et maintenir un palier euh donc
suffisant pour permettre le contrôle de
l'ensemble de de la chaudière de manière
à éventuellement suspecter détecter tout
toute
anomalie donc ça c'est bien euh un
examen physique qui est fait et qui est
fait euh et qui est assumé par par
laasn Monsieur le Président peut-être
juste un complément c'est c'est
Jean-Marc mirour ici donc je vouis
simplement dire que tous les
enregistrements des contrôles de la cuve
les radiographies les contrôles ultra
sont évidemment conservé pendant toute
la vie de la centrale et peuvent donner
lieu à des relectures en particulier par
l'Autorité de sûreté à tout moment
oui d'ailleurs pour pour l'anecdote on
peut parler de feu notre collègue
Pelchat qui avait été responsable de la
découverte enfin des méthodes d'analyse
qui ont permis de découvrir les fissures
ou les microofissures plus exactement
sur les couvercles de cuve
Christian
bille
oui monsieuroudra oui alors de questions
en
stock donc al sur la question donc
secret industriel et et impact par
rapport aux réponses qui peuvent être
faites à l'autorité de Sté nucléaire
donc donc ce que j'ai indiqué donc
conformément l'objectif de transparence
de la loi de 2006 de juin 2006 c'est que
les actes de l'ASN donc de l'ASN qui
sont rédigés à à la suite du contrôle
des exploitants sont rendus public donc
sur internet de de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire
euh ensuite les réponses que font les
exploitants à à ses courriers euh sont
transmis à l'autorité de Sté nucléaire
avec effectivement certain nombre de
questions qui peuvent porter atteinte à
des questions de de secret secret
industriel euh puisque ce sont
effectivement des réponses dont on
attend euh qu'elles aient un niveau de
détail qui peut être parfois euh
extrêmement important avec des dossiers
extrêmement
volumineux les exploitants sont tenus de
par la loi euh de répondre euh enfin de
fournir ces informations à l'autorité de
srité nucléaire donc c'est un des
articles de la loi TSN euh qui l'indique
et euh par ailleurs les les inspecteurs
de l'autorité de sé nucléaire sont de
fait à astraint
à une obligation de de de ne pas mettre
en péril les éventuelles information
relev relevant de de secret industriel
ou
commercial pour la question donc portant
sur les les stress test européen et
globalement la
l'harmonisation de ce qui peut être fait
en terme de contrôle de la seté
nucléaire en Europe donc il faut savoir
que c'est effectivement un des objectifs
que l'ASN porte depuis depuis longtemps
depuis largement avant Fukushima laasn
étant notamment à l'origine de la
création de l'association WENRA Western
European nuclear regulatory association
qui est donc l'association regroupant
les les chefs des autorités de sûreté
nucléaire européennes qui travaillent
depuis
donc d'assez longues années maintenant à
dans un dans une optique d'élévation des
exigences de sûreté une certaine
harmonisation de la définition des
exigences au niveau européen c'est une
association qui a travaillé euh à la
suite de Fukushima justement pour
établir un projet de de cahier des
charges encadrant les les stress tests
qui en vue donc d'alimenter ce qui
pourrait être endossé par par la
Commission européenne qui relève
effectivement d'une décision politique
euh pour la la question euh de la
sécurité des installations
nucléaire donc là les compétences sont
sont partagées l'ASN est en charge du
contrôle de la sûreté des installation
c'est-à-dire donc typiquement si on
s'intéresse aux questions des des actes
de
malveillance les conséquences sur la
sûreté donc les conséquences en TER de
de risque d'accident notamment
d'un d'un acte de malveillance laasn
n'est pas en charge euh du contrôle de
la protection des installations
nucléaires contre les actes de
malveillance euh c'est le haut
fonctionnaire de défense et de sécurité
du ministère en charge de
l'environnement qui est en charge de ces
aspectsl
euh pour ce qui concerne la la déf la
dernière question je
crois non enfin c'est une entité
administrative dont le nom est le haut
fonctionnaire de défense et de sécurité
vous avez été au ministère de
l'Environnement je suppose que vous avez
quand même rencontré le haut
fonctionnaire de
défense la la dernière question donc
touchant la la question de la défection
des des personnels euh permet d'insister
effectivement euh sur un point que j'ai
pas développé dans le cadre de la
présentation parce que c'était focalisé
sur les aspects matériels conformment à
l'ordre du jour sur le fait que
effectivement l'homme et l'organisation
euh ont enfin les hommes et et
l'organisation les organisations ont un
rôle cent centrale dans la garantie de
la sûreté de la radioprotection de la
protection de l'environnement pour ce
qui concerne une centrale nucléaire et
une installation nucléaire plus
largement c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
motivé l'ASN à s'intéresser à ces sujets
de manière approfondie de depuis de
nombreuses années et notamment donc dans
le cadre des évaluations complémentaires
de sûreté engagé à la suite de
l'accident de Fukushima à demander aux
exploitant de
réanalyser notamment sur la base des
enseignements directs de Fukushima
les capacités par exemple d'intervention
en situation accidentelle des personnes
les implications que les éventuelles
limitations de de de ces interventions
pourrai avoir sur la gestion d'un
accident de regarder aussi plus
largement la question du de
l'organisation générale et notamment la
répartition entre les tâches
sous-traitées les tâches qui ne sont pas
sous-traitées donc il il y a
effectivement l'ensemble de ces aspects
qui sont couvertes dans les évaluations
complémentaires de sûreté c'est c'est
aussi des aspects sur lequels il est
extrêmement légitime de ser interroger
et de regarder si euh on ne peut pas
encore progressir sur ces aspect
là Christian batille puis Bruno sidau
oui deux
questions qui ne sont pas à l'cnotique à
l'adresse de EDF
euh les les problèmes aériens mettre en
mett en exerg aujourd'hui le le débat
entre le le facteur humain et et facteur
technique donc je veux venir sur le
plutôt le facteur humain
euh nous avons visité la semaine
dernière la la centrale de Graveline et
nous avons appris que des personnes
avaient été découvertes à l'intérieur
d'un camion à l'entrée de la centrale
alors quels sont je vous demande de de
nous dire quelles sont les les mesures
mise en œuvre pour empêcher les
intrusions sur les sites des centrales
France française en général et ma
deuxième question porte
sur le le contrôle nous avons visité
également à Graveline un poste de
simulation de pilotage à l'entrée d'une
centrale nucléaire et ce pilotage est
très centralisé il est effectué par
quatre
personnes seulement pourrait-on dire
alors que se passerait-il si par
exemple dans un moment de démence ou ou
autre un des pilotes voulait prendre le
contrôle de la centrale est-elle
exclusivement pilotable depuis ce poste
ou bien peut-on reprendre le contrôle du
réacteur depuis un autre
endroit bruno
Sido toujours dans le dans le facteur
humain la question s'adresse à EDF qui
nous a expliqué avec beaucoup de talent
les systèmes de secours et d'urgence
prévu en cas d'accident sur un réacteur
mais à
Fukushima on a vu en évidence que des
phénomènes de cause commune pouvaient
toucher simultanément plusieurs
réacteurs sur un même site je pense
Gravel
par qui qui a quand même si réacteurs
autant qu'à
fukushimai et ma question c'est eston
sûr que les moyens matériels disponibles
et lesy hum
permettrait de faire face simultanément
à des situations accidentelles multiples
sur un même site mais sur plusieurs
réacteurs c'était ma première
question ma deuxème question c'est que
l'acent a été mis à juste titre sur le
cœur du réacteur c'était le cœur de
notre c'est le cœur de notre sujet
aujourd'hui où se trouve en
fonctionnement dans des conditions les
plus pénalisantes de température et de
pression et de dégagement d'énergie bon
c'est clair mais on l'a vu d'ailleurs à
Fukushima du fait justement des progrès
réalisés sur la protection du cœur le
point faible de nos centrales se serait
peut-être déplacé et ne serait-il pas
devenu la piscine de refroidissement du
combustible qui est beaucoup moins bien
protégé contre les agressions externes
on l'a vu elle n'est pas certes
au-dessus du réacteur comme à Fukushima
elle n'est pas à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte de confinement non plus et et
bénéficie de de moins de système de
secours redondant semble-t-il tout au
moins voilà donc pouvez-vous nous dire
finalement ce qu'il en est des piscines
et du danger parce que si les piscines
sont plus refroidies non plus il peut y
avoir échauffement et que peut-il se
passer alors alors oui monsieur mirokou
voilà en ce qui concerne donc votre
question relative à Graveline donc là il
s'agissait d'événement d'intrusion de
clandestins dans des camions bon est
évident que il y a des mesures de
contrôle supplémentaires avec des
portiques qui ont été mis en place et il
y a nous avons également une action de
renforcement des forces de gendarmerie
présentes sur les sites même à
l'intérieur des sites dédiés à la
protection des sites nucléaires alors
c'est une vigilance de tous les instants
mais nous avons renforcé suite à cet
incident là en particulier le contrôle
lors des
portiques avec voilà inspection des
camions et nous faisons a ce que nous
appelons des rupture de charge
c'est-à-dire que nous déchargeons les
camions et ce sont des camions à
l'intérieur de qui sont dédiés au
transport à l'intérieur de la centrale
qui reprennent les charges pour des
charges lourdes en particulier lors des
arrêts de tranche pour maintenance pour
apporter le matériel dans les
installations nucléaires elle-même en ce
qui concerne la salle de commande donc
vous avez vu le le simulateur qui est la
réplique exacte d'une salle de
commande de toute façon ce qu'il faut
bien avoir présent à l'esprit c'est
qu'en cas de déviation ou de de l'un
quelconque des paramètres qui assurent
la sûreté de la centrale vous avez arrêt
automatique de la centrale donc ça ça
vaut pour des je dirais des causes de
défaillance de matériel mais ça peut
valoir aussi pour des causes humaines
donc si un opérateur et malheureusement
ça
arrive non pas pour des causes de
malveillance d'opérateur mais tout
simplement parce que l'erreur est
humaine et que les opérateurs il peut
leur arriver de de de faire une action
inappropriée vous avez immédiatement
arrêt d'urgence du réacteur c'est ce qui
explique d'ailleurs que nous ayons sur
le le parc français environ une
cinquantaine d'arrêts d'urgence par an
dû à ce type de cause donc première
chose c'est vous avez arrêt automatique
du réacteur en cas de de d'action
inappropriée cette action pouvant être
humaine ensuite donc en cas
de d'accident d'accident donc en
particulier pour couvrir des causes où
la la salle de commande serait
inhabitable vous avez une autre salle de
commande alors naturellement plus
réduite qui est située ailleurs dans le
bâtiment électrique de et souvent un
autre étage du bâtiment électrique vous
avez une autre salle de commande ande
plus réduite mais qui permet également
de de contrôler la de contrôler la
centrale et puis infin alors évidemment
ce sont plus des des moyens de de
conseil et d'analyse mais vous avez
l'organisation nationale de crise qui se
met en place qui est une ligne d'analyse
et de de de diagnostic et de pronostic
supplémentaire en cas d'accident sur la
centrale qui viendrait qui viendrait on
le voit lors des n nombreux exercices
qui sont faits chaque
année conseiller voir un demander aux
opérateurs pour reprendre en main la
centrale de réaliser telle ou telle
action donc il y a également une
redondance humaine sur les les causes
communes de défaillance de plusieurs
réacteurs sur un même site donc
certaines de ces causes sont déjà prises
en
compte il est et nous l'avons dit dès le
départ l'un des enseignements de de
Fukushima porte sur ce type de situation
donc ça fait compl c'est au cœur des des
des des stress tests et des situations
que nous examinons suite à Fukushima
surtout les moyens humains pardonnez-moi
il y a et les moyens humains qui vont
avec donc des moyens humains et donc
nous nous examinons ça sous deux volets
complémentaires sur le site lui-même
donc des moyens matériels et des moyens
humains pour mettre en place des sur le
site lui-même des moyens supplémentaires
pour faire face à des accidents sur
plusieurs réacteurs et également c'est
un des axes que nous avons lancé de dès
le début des moyens nationaux euh donc
euh à la fois matériel et humain
permettant de prendre le relais de
secourir un un un site tout
particulièrement dans les situations où
plusieurs réacteurs voire tous les
réacteurs d'un même site seraient
concernés par un accident puis en ce qui
concerne les piscines donc
j'ai j'ai je l'ai pas détaillé dans ma
présentation mais la conception des
piscines vis-à-vis des piscines de
stockage de combustible usé vis-à-vis du
séisme vis-à-vis des inondations et
prend en compte le même niveau d'aléa
que pour les réacteurs vous vous êtes à
l'intérieur de ce que nous appelons
l'illo nucléaire dans l'ilo nucléaire
vous avez le réacteur dans son asè de
confinement et la piscine de stockage
l'ensemble de l'îon nucléaire doit
satisfaire aux mêmes exigences de sûreté
pour le refroidissement des piscines des
circuits de refroidissement des piscines
nous avons un circuit de refroidissement
redondant donc là aussi avec deux deux
systèmes de système dont deux trains
dont un seul train suffit à remplir la
fonction bon la la la robustesse de ce
système fait également l'objet de
d'examen et de réexamen dans le cas de
l'action dans le cadre de l'action post
Fukushima merci du côté de l'ASN ou de
l'IRSN vous avez des compléments à
apporter non ce n'est pas le cas euh
monsieur Tourtelier
oui c'est une question technique parce
que pour être sûr d'avoir bien tout
compris quand on a visité euh le
chantier de l'pr donc euh et vous avez
dit que c'était un un des des apports de
l'pr à supposer qu'on a jusqu'à la
fusion du cœur il est récupéré et vous
avez à ce moment-là un stockage d'eau
qui se déverse automatiquement pour
refroidir mais à ce moment-là il y a
dégagement de vapeur qu'est-ce qu'elle
devient cette vapeur
oui c'est pour cela que j'ai précisé que
le système était passif dans un dans un
premier état et ensuite effectivement il
y a dégagement de vapeur augmentation de
pression et c'est pour C que il est
quand même nécessaire au bout d' certain
temps de pouvoir actionner l'aspersion
pour faire baisser la pression à et la
température à l'intérieur du bâtiment
donc c'est c'é quelque chose qui est en
deux phases la première est passive et
la deuxième doit être active la deuxième
doit arriver dans quel délai
euh une douzaine
d'heures en gros donc il y a quand même
pas mal de
temps euh avant monsieur Cochet derrière
monsieur Cochet il y avait quelqu'un qui
voulait poser une question vous vous
présentez pour le contre-rendu oui
Sylvain David physicien CNRS et membre
du comité
d'experts il a été évoqué les
turbopompes j'ai cru comprendre qu'à
Fukushima ces turbopompes existaient
donc c'est c'est c'est des machines qui
sont faites pour si j'ai bien compris
continuer à refroidir le cœur si on a
une perte totale d'alimentation
électrique il semblerait qu'elles n'ont
pas fonctionné parce que les vannes qui
dévient la chaleur vers les la la vapeur
vers les turbopompes fonctionnent à l'
cité je voulais savoir ce qu'il en était
sur les réacteurs français et un peu
dans le même type de
question le filtre qui permet de
capturer la majorité du césium et une
partie de liode existait aussi à
Fukushima si je me trompe vous vous me
reprenez mais il a pas été possible de
de dégazer via ces filtres et donc toute
la radioactivité est sortie encore une
fois est-ce qui je voulais savoir la
situation en France est-ce que les
circuits qui emmènent le le gaz
radioactif sont redondants par exemple
et dernière remarque j'ai été surpris de
pas entendre parler beaucoup des
batteries de secours ultime et donc je
voulais savoir où elles étaient placées
est-ce qu'elles étaient aussi
redondantes et par exemple dans le Pr
est-ce qu'elles sont est-ce qu'il y en a
quatre dans chaque dans chacun des
quatre bâtiments réacteurs et combien de
temps en gros ell tiennent
merci président oui monsieur Servier oui
je peux peut-être apporter quelques
éléments de de réponse à ces différents
aspects conc ant Fukushima sur les
tranches 2 et 3 en particulier il y a
effectivement des systèmes turbopompe
qui permettent d'envoyer l'eau dans le
réacteur et qui fonctionne à la vapeur
alors ces turbopompes elles nécessitent
un contrôle commande pour fonctionner et
elles se sont effectivement arrêté en
quelque sorte
lorsque les réserves des batteries sont
tombé en panne donc au bout d'un certain
nombre
d'heures dans nos install tion où nous
avons des turbopompes qui ont pas tout à
fait les même fonction mais Don le
principe de fonctionnement est le même
pour l'alimentation are secours des des
générateurs de vapeur en particulier
c'est la même chose il faut que le
contrôle commande fonctionne ce que nous
avons comme disposition qui est
d'ailleurs un retour d'expérience des
incidents antérieurs c'est qu'il y a un
petit turbo générateur supplémentaire
qui fonctionne à la vapeur mais qui
fabrique de l'électricité pour alimenter
le le contrôle commande en CE
cours en ce qui concerne les filtres
systèm
dévantage à ma
connaissance les dispositifs d'vantage
de
Fukushima ne sont pas équipés de de
filtres de même type que ce que on a sur
les installations françaises mais
surtout ce qu'il faut noter c'est que
les décompressions les avantages qu'ils
ont été amenés à effectuer n'ont pas été
fait avec les
systèmes norm prévu à cet effet là parce
que ils avaient en fait perdu l'aair de
de commande pour ouvrir les vannes du
système d'vantage normal avant le moment
où ils en ont eu effectivement
besoin donc ça c'est un des points
effectivement aussi important c'est de
s'assurer que les dispositifs de
secours de type évantage ont la capacité
de fonctionn avec le contrôle commande
air comprimé ou électricité qui va bien
d'où l'utilité de des petits générateurs
supplémentaires à vapeur que on que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure pour le
contrôle commande des des
turbine en ce qui concerne les batteries
il y a des batteries qui sont implantées
dans chaque train de de secours
électrique et qui sont structurés de la
même façon que la redondance des
systèmes donc quand on a des systèmes
d'ordre 2 le contrôle command et les
batteries qui vont avec sont organisé en
deux trains quand dans le Pr quand c'est
en quatre train benah il y a qure train
de de batterie qui qui fonctionn
là-dessus et les batteries sont en
général installées au passage dans des
étages qui sont pas au niveau du du sol
mais un petit peu plus élevés donc
généralement hors d'eau vis-à-vis de
risque d'inondation qui soit interne ou
externe enfin d'origine interne ou
externe je crois que voilà les quelques
éléments que je souhaitais vous apporter
en
réponse monsieur comess je j'ajouterai
que sur le Pr donc en plus des batteries
dites normales que Monsieur Servier
vient de décrire il y a un jeu de
batterie supplémentaire dit batterie
accident grave avec une autonomie de 12
he qui permettrait de garder de
l'électricité pour le contrôle commande
l'éclairage un peu de ventilation
pendant une douzaine d'heure de garder
cette autonomie laissant la possibilité
éventuellement de ramener des moyens
mobiles et c'est complètement diversifié
par rapport aux batteries
normales
une question complémentaire de Monsieur
Cochet euh oui c'est à propos de
d'informatique on peut dire parce
que toutes ces installations évidemment
sont très électronisées alors il y a
d'une part du point de vue alors je sais
pas si c'est la sûreté ou la sécurité
mais c'est les intrusions de virus sur
les systèmes informatiques il y a des
champions du monde vous savez bon qu'on
les hackeurs enfin qui font du
terrorisme informatique qui vont très
loin même quelquefois dans des
ministères de la Défense de pays et
cetera donc de quelle manière euh d'une
part est-ce que vous exploitant vous
avez déjà eu euh des des incidents de de
virus ou de chevaux de TR qui qui se
sont infiltrés dans vos systèmes par
exemple de contrôle commande de réacteur
est-ce que ça a déjà existé et sinon bah
quelles sont est-ce que c'est simplement
dire de la sécurité informatique
classique on qu'on on achète sur le
marché ou bien est-ce que vous avez vos
propres systèm disons d'autodéfense
informatique là je parle plus de de
tuyauterie ou quoi que ce soit c'est de
l'informatique alors également une
deuxème et dernière question de type
informatique lorsque on détecte quelque
chose ça veut dire qu'il y a un
détecteur qui vous a dit qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se passe mais on ne
sait pas si c'est la réalité par exemple
une petite fissure sur le cœur ENF ça
c'est très grave ou bien si c'est le
détecteur lui-même j' dire qui est plus
ou moins fiable ou défaillant peut-être
que c'est un manomètre qui commence à
être vieillissant et qui envoie une
information qu'il y a une montée de
pression mais que il y a pas de montée
de pression c'est le manomètre lui-même
je prends une image évidemment que tout
le monde connaît parce que finalement
une centrale nucléaire ça consiste à
chauffer de l'eau en faire bouillir de
l'eau en gros hein comme bon et bien
quelle est la la la logique informatique
qui préside à vos systèmes de détection
est est-ce que c logique on pourrait
dire en tout ou rien dès que il y a un
manomètre sur les 150 qui monte je parle
un manomètre c'est c'est évidemment
paradigmatique hein ça peut être tout
autre chose ilons un capteur de quelque
chose qui détecte que ça va pas est-ce
que c'est une logique donc en tout ou
rien un seul évidemment qui ferait
passer un seuil de de dangerosité à la
centrale et à ce moment-là on a des
mesures ou bien est-ce que c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une alors du
point de vue informatique strictement
une logique majoritaire c'estàd il
faudrait
que il y ait une majorité justement de
ces capteurs qui détecte un seuil de
pression ou autre chose et à ce
moment-là il peut y avoir une
défaillance d'un ou deux capteurs bah
c'est pas grave on laisse tomber c'est
comme s'il se passait
rien oui d'accord d'accord la question
en ce qui concerne la l'informatique
donc les problème des virus donc là
aussi l'AR architecture euh est conçu
suivant un système de de de défense en
profondeur et le le noyau dur de tout ce
qui commande ou tout ce qui reçoit des
informations du process nucléaire
lui-même et de tout ce qui touche à la
sûreté est isolé du reste c'est-à-dire
il n'y a pas de liaison entre le système
de contrôle commande euh de du qui
assure la protection et le contrôle du
réacteur il n'y a pas de liaison avec
l'extérieur de la centrale donc il n'y a
pas de possibilité physique
d'introduction d'un virus par
l'extérieur en ce qui concerne la
possibilité de virus nous avons eu
effectivement des virus sur les
centrales nucléaires mais qui par nature
et par le principe de conception que je
viens de de de donné n'a affecté que on
va dire les systèmes tertiaires les
systèmes de
gestion des des systèmes tertiaires de
la centrale et n'a pas pu physiquement
pour le principe que je viens de
rappeler se communiquer au système du
contrôle de ce que nous appelons le
contrôle commande industriel de de
l'installation en ce qui concerne les
les capteurs donc j'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans mes transparents que pour
le système de protection il y avait des
redondances j'ai dit que il y avait en
particulier redondance d'ordre 4 dans
les systèmes qui assurent la protection
et en particulier et la protection
automatique donc ce qui veut dire que
par exemple pour prendre votre exemple
qui est tout à fait fondé de manomètres
c'est-à-dire de de capteurs de pression
pour un une même pression par exemple la
pression dans le circuit primaire il y a
quatre capteurs qui mesure en permanence
le même paramètre il y a une
intercomparaison dans le contrôle
commande des mesures qui sont données
par chacune par chacun de ces quatre
capteurs et ensuite vous avez une
logique donc en 2/ 4 voire en 2/ 3 dès
l'instant que vous avez en particulier
la défaillance de l'un des capteurs et
c'est toute cette analyse de fiabilité
de l'architecture y compris au travers
de ces capteurs qui qui fait l'objet
comme le disait monsieur Jorel au début
des études probabilistes de sûreté et
donc on mesure la fiabilité de ces
capteurs on mesure la fiabilité de
l'architecture par la redondance et
ensuite on calcule la fiabilité de
l'installation et vous voyez que là
aussi les les problèmes de défaillance
de capteur ou de dérive de capteur sont
pris en compte au travers de la
redondance
merci quelqu'un souhaite ajouter quelque
chose est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions y compris parmi les
journalistes non je n'en vois pas euh
donc
contenu de l'heure ben nous terminons
juste à l'heure donc je suis désolé mais
il y aura pas de pause donc nous allons
continuer et c'est Christian Bataille
qui va prendre la présidence de la 2e
table ronde
Mesdames et Messieurs chers
collègues la deuxe session de cette
audition a pour objet de mettre en
valeur les efforts de recherche qui
soutendent les progrès permanents de la
sûreté en ce qui concerne
particulièrement les dispositifs de
défense en
profondeur d'ailleurs je veux indiquer à
nos auditeurs que les différentes
visites que nous avons déjà fa tant
à tant à nos gens sur scène qu'à
Graveline qu'à flamandville on ont
permis de mesurer en grandeur réelle ce
souci
aujourd'hui nous allons examiner ces
efforts de recherche qui se situent à
différents niveaux et concernent aussi
bien les matériaux des équipements sous
pression les systèmes comme par exemple
les logiciels de command qui sont
constamment perfectionné mais aussi les
bétons dont nous n'avons pas parlé
jusqu'alors il concerne également les
moyens de surveillance et de mesure
puisque l'opérateur japonais Tepco s'est
trouvé après la double catastrophe du
séisme et du tsunami presque aussi
aveugle vis-à-vis de la situation dans
les dans ces installations que
l'opérateur américain de la centrale de
freemand l'été en
79 nos
intervenants dont vous avez la liste
vont nous apporter différents éclairages
sur ces recherches soit pour en
présenter les différents axes soit plus
ponctuellement pour décrire de façon
plus détaillée l'intérêt de certaines
innovations notre premier
intervenant est au cœur de la
problématique de recherche sur la sûreté
des réacteurs puisqu'il s'agit de
Monsieur Christophe
Bard directeur de l'énergie nucléaire au
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives selon le nouvel
intitulé au sigle du CA monsieur
cocher je le
précise voilà Monsieur Serge Béard vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
merci je vais vous parler RD qui est
mené au sein du CEA selon cinq grands
axes que je vais vous décrire ensuite je
vous signale immédiatement et je seraiis
amené à le préciser au cours de mon
exposé que ces études sont menées assez
largement soit en collaboration avec EDF
àeva
l'IRSN soit en collaboration
internationale et j'ai vu que ça faisait
partie d'un point des exposés de la
suite de la journée pour chacun des
problèmes sous
je
parlerai de la nature de ce problème des
acquis que nous pensons déjà avoir
aujourd'hui et de ce qu'il reste à faire
je vous diraiis immédiatement que nous
consacrons à ces études à peu près 24
millions d'euros par an
aujourd'hui alors si
j'ai les
transparent ce serait une excellente
chose merci beaucoup donc j'ai fait une
séparation somme tout som tout assez
classique en accident de dimensionnement
et accident hors dimensionnement vous
voyez que il y en a cinq l'accident de
perte de réfrigérant primaire à PRP je
serai parfois un peu technique je vous
prie de m'en excuser j'essaierai de le
faire oublier immédiatement en vous
disant ce que nous avons fait en terme
peut-être plus appréhendables
ce type d'accident de perte de
réfrigérant primaire c'est une
problématique que nous avons rencontré
dans le cadre de Fukushima nous
travaillons sur des accidents de
réactivité nous travaillons aussi sur la
problématique de l'hydrogène en
particulier la création de l'hydrogène
mais son comportement dans dans des
enceintes de grande taille et ça
évidemment c'est quelque chose que nous
avons rencontré dans le cadre de
Fukushima nous travaillons sur la
rupture des gaines de combustible le
relâchement et le transport des produits
de fission et ça c'est une problématique
spécifique de Fukushima et enfin last
but nottice nous avons travaillé nous
travaillons encore sur la création et le
comportement du corium le corium j'en
dis juste de mots c'est du combustible
fondu des résidus de combustible en tout
cas considéré que c'est un corps qui est
porté à très haute température et qui va
interagir avec trois domaines que sont
la cuve du réacteur l'eau et
éventuellement si on a du corium qui
vient interagir avec l'eau et puis le
béton situé sous la cuve du
réacteur alors le premier élément que je
veux aborder celui dans le domaine des
accidents de dimensionnement de la perte
de réfrigérant primaire on va regarder
la courbe qui est en haut vous avez en
abscisse le temps en ordonnée la
température et on va regarder
l'évolution de la température de la
gaine en fonction du temps à partir d'un
accident qui est celui la perte de
réfrigérant primaire c'est-à-dire qu'on
arrête de refroidir le cœur et on se
rend compte de plusieurs choses d'une
part la température de la gaine va
augmenter simultanément la pression à
l'intérieur de la cuve du réacteur
nucléaire va diminuer la
pression interne à la gaine varie de
typiquement 95 bares à 140 bares en
fonction du temps que celle-ci a passé
en cœur de réacteur donc nous sommes
dans une configuration où euh la
pression interne de la gaine est donnée
la pression externe diminue et on va
avoir à un moment un éclatement de cette
gaine c'est ce qui figure sur la courbe
au niveau de l'étoile vous voyez qu'à un
moment la température diminue et on
retrouve des phénomènes qui ont été
décrit tout à l'heure décharge des
accumulateurs c'est-à-dire qu'on va
reprendre le refroidissement du cœur une
fois que les accumulateurs ont été
déchargé on va avoir une remontée en
pression lentere jusqu'à une injection
de sécurité moyen une pression qui se
situe typiquement aux alentours de 40
bares le problème qui est posé c'est
bien celui de la capacité à refroidir le
cœur après rupture complète de la
tuyauterie principale je l'ai dit de la
boucle primaire et pour ce problème
particulier là la tenue mécanique des
gaines des crayons de combustible ce que
nous savons faire aujourd'hui c'est la
modisation du ballonnement et de la
rupture de gain du combustible et son
comportement après renoyage du cœur
parce que je ne l'ai pas dit ce que j'ai
signalé simplement c'est que
euh ces gaines de combustible
subissaient des changements qui peuvent
être important vous le voyez de
température et subissait aussi des
changements métallurgiques et le
problème qu' nous faut traiter
aujourd'hui c'est celui de la malisation
en 3D de la gaine de combustible parce
qu'il n'y a pas symétrie complète selon
que l'on prend telle telle ou telle
partie de la gaine c'est le premier
point et le deuxième point c'est les
interactions mécaniques éventuelles
entre crayon
combustible le deuxième sujet que nous
travaillons est celui des accidents de
réactivité donc accidents de réactivité
ça a été
abordé tout à l'heure donc ces accidents
de réactivités peuvent se produire
lorsque nous avons une éjection de barre
de contrôle on en a parlé en ce cas la
puissance le nombre de neutrons
peut-être multiplié en un temps très
court par un nombre important ce qui va
se
traduire par une augmentation très forte
de la température du combustible donc on
produit plus de puissance la température
monte brutalement en quelques dizaines
de millisecondes et qu'est-ce qui va se
passer on va créer à l'intérieur du
combustible à l'intérieur de la gaine
une quantité importante de produits de
fission et ces produits de fission vont
avoir tendance à pousser les pastilles
de combustible vers la gain et on va
voir une Inter action mécanique
extrêmement importante dite interaction
pastig
gaine ce travail là a est en cours
d'examen en particulier au sein de
l'installation cabri qui est en cours de
construction à cadarche le problème posé
je vous l'ai dit c'est définir les
critères de tenue du combustible lors
d'un transitoire très rapide quelques
dizaines de millisecondes je l'ai dit de
puissance et de température consécutif à
l'éjection intempestive d'une barre de
contrôle et ce que nous devons faire
dans le casre du programme international
cabri lorsque celui-ci sera opérationnel
c'est l'étude du comportement du
combustible après ballonnement rupture
et pourquoi pas l'étude de nouveaux
matériaux de gain et de
combustible le troisième type d'accident
dont je voudrais parler c'est celui de
la problématique de l'hydrogène je vais
me focaliser sur le comportement
l'hydrogène dans un grand volume
simplement ce que je veux dire et je
vais pas euh être très long à ce sujet
c'est que dans le cas des analyses que
nous avons été amenés à faire au sein du
CEA dans le cadre de la problématique de
Fukushima nous sommes rendus compte que
dans certains cas de figure la quantité
d'hydrogène créé était pour nous parfois
un peu difficile à appréhender dit
autrement les outils dont nous
disposions pour déterminer la quantité
initiale d'hydrogène créé devait être
très probablement amélioré ceci étant si
je me place dans une configuration
où cet hydrogène a été créé soit par
oxydation forte des gaines de
combustible soit sur le plus long terme
par des réaction d'interaction des
rayonnements avec de l'eau c'est ce
qu'on appelle la radiolyse le problème
posé est celui l'inflammabilité des
risques d'explosion alors on a un
diagramme magnifique qui s'appelle le
diagramme de chapirot qui nous dit que
lorsque la concentration d'hydrogène est
comprise entre 4 et 75° et 75 % pardon
en volume dans l'air bah on risque
d'avoir de l'in l'inflammabilité ou bien
l'explosion le problème qui se pose là
c'est de savoir comment
l'hydrogène se détend dans l'enceinte
comment il va se mélanger avec l'oxygène
et ce qu'il est important de faire c'est
euh de continuer à modéliser les
processus de développement de
l'explosion à travailler sur la gestion
de l'atmosphère gazeuse de l'enceinte
par la mesure et la modisation et ce
qu'il y a derrière bien entendu c'est la
problématique des fameux recombineurs
d'hydrogène dont on a parlé est-ce qu'on
les place à tel endroit tel endroit en
tel en quelle quantité et cetera et
cetera et puis une conséquence d'une
explosion éventuelle c'est l'impact
mécanique évidemment des explosions sur
les structures alors nous travaillons
dans le cadre d'un projet international
OCDE et d'un projet européen qui le
projet
acosam qui doit se terminer fin 2013 sur
une installation qui est positionnée à
saclle qui est une installation un bidon
d'une centaine de mètres CB dans lequel
on est capable de faire de faire des
mesures de distribution d'hydrogène qui
peuvent nous permettre de répondre aux
problématiques
posées le sujet suivant sur lequel nous
sommes amenés à à travailler c'est la
problématique de la rupture des gaines
de combustible le problème posé et vous
le savez on a été amené à en parler
suffisamment lorsque l'accident de
Fukushima s produit c'est le relâchement
et le transport des produits de fission
en cas de rupture ou de fusion partielle
ou total des gaines de combustible du
réacteur donc la question posée on a
bien sûr des éléments là-dessus mais
c'est quels éléments on va retrouver et
où à l'intérieur du réacteur on a
aujourd'hui de bonnes connaissances pour
le combustible UO2
actuel par contre nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire de compléter les études sur
d'autres types de combustibles en
particulier le MOX il faut étudier les
les phénomènes de dépôt et de
revolatilisation c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
avoir un produit de fission qui va se
déposer à un moment dans un endroit qui
est froid mais ce celui-ci par exemple
s'il est chauffé dans le cas du
déroulement de l'accident peut être à
nouveau euh remis euh en suspension dans
l'air ou bien lors des entrées d'air
dans les circuits il faut améliorer la
simulation du transport de ces produits
de fission enfin il faut étudier
l'impact des conditions de renoyage du
cœur donc nous avons une installation
aujourd'hui euh à cadarche qui s'appelle
l'installation Verdon qui est destinée à
simuler le
comportement d'un d'une rupture de gaine
de combustible c'est un programme qui
est international et qui regroupe
EDF GDF suè laanrc américaine
l'IRSN enfin et je terminerai par ce
point qui est aussi
important je vous le disais en
introduction c'est la problématique du
corium donc la question qui se pose à
nous c'est la suivante c'est ce corium
je l'ai dit il va se créer en cuve lié à
la fusion des crayons de combustible une
première question que nous nous posons
c'est ce corium en cuve comment il va se
comporter et la question posée c'est
quel est quels sont les flux de chaleur
qu'il va transmettre à la cuve du
réacteur parce que derrière ce qui se
pose la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire tenir la
cuve donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose la deuxième point qui est
important c'est supposons que ce corium
viennent en interaction avec de l'eau
c'est-à-dire imaginez quelque chose qui
est très chaud qui va venir couler dans
un liquide qui est de l'eau qui existe
évidemment dans des systèmes de ce type
qu'est-ce qui va se passer on va avoir
des petites gouttes de métal très chaud
qui va venir en interaction avec l'eau
on va créer une gaine de vapeur autour
de ce corium et pour des raisons qui
sont pas encore bien définis on peut
avoir ce qu'on appelle une explosion
vapeur c'est une explosion extrêmement
forte par une espèce d'agrégation des
différents matelas de vapeur créés à
l'intérieur du liquide et enfin la trè
chose c'est la problématique éventuelle
de l'interaction du corium avec le béton
on il y a énormément d'études qui ont
été faites on se r compte que selon les
types de béton l'interaction du corium
avec le béton peut-être très notablement
différente donc qu'est-ce que nous avons
acquis la compréhension des phénomènes
de dégradation du combustible et des
structures la progression du corium en
cuve et hors cuve avec quand même
quelques points d'interrogation qui pour
moi reste à préciser la physique
relative à l'érosion thermique du béton
du radié et l'explosion vapeur ceci
étant nous avons encore du travail à
faire fortement sur ce sujet me
semble-t-il le renoyage et la
refroissabilité des lites débris et du
corium c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui se
passe si je viens remettre de l'eau sur
le système la rétention du corium en
cuve par refroidissement externe de la
cuve donc la question c'est la suivante
c'est
euh le problème physique que je vous
décrivais tout à l'heure donc vous avez
un corium en fond de cuve si je veux
refroidir ce corium à l'intérieur de la
cuve pour éviter qu'il la perce et bien
à nouveau quels sont les flux thermiques
qui vont passer vers l'extérieur l'étude
des systèmes de mitigation vis-à-vis de
du risque de percement du radiier
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'on a des
systèmes qui per ex en français sa
mitigation oui absolument ah bon c'est
limiter les conséquences de c'est comme
ça que je le traduirai je pense que si
vous avez d'autres traductions je suis
je suis preneur mais je pense qu'en
français ça se dit comme vous venez de
le
dire et non pas mitigation euh je dis
pas mitigation mais je vous entends
c'est ce qui est important c'est qu'on
se comprenne enfin la modéisation des
conséquences mécaniques de l'explosion
vapeur sur les structures comme je
décrivais tout à l'heure alors nous
avons des programmes expérimentaux qui
existent qui sont faits en collaboration
avec nos partenaires comme ce que je
citais auparavant EDF Areva l'IRSN mais
nous avons aussi des partenariats avec
des pays à l'international au travers de
projets auocde j'en ai cité un ici qui
est le projet
Serena voilà monsieur le Président je
vous remercie je vais être obligé
d'aller de vous quitter je suis amené à
aller discuter avec l'Europe entre
autres sur ces problématiqu là je vous
remercie beaucoup
qu'est-ce qui répond aux questions pour
le CEA écoutez je si vous si vous pensez
qu'il est possible de poser des
questions maintenant j''y répondrai très
non les questions elles viennent à la
fin oui non sinon une réponse ah non on
va pas me donner une réponse moi je veux
savoir s'il y a des questions qui sont
adressées au CEA qui peut
répondre bah écoutez je vais répondre je
prendrai un train bien plus tard
d'accord alors nous passons au deuxième
intervenant qui est Monsieur Jean-Claude
Michelli directeur de la prévention des
risques majeurs à
l'IRSN et qui va maintenant faire le
point sur les travaux menés par l'IRSN
dans ses propres laboratoires et ceux de
ses partenaires académiques le plus
souvent dans le cadre des coopérations
nationales et
internationales aussi bien dans le
domaine de la prévention des accidents
que dans celui de la limitation de leurs
conséquences monsieur Micheli nous vous
écoutons merci monsieur le
Président donc je je vous propose de
oui ah ok d'enchaîner immédiatement avec
le le le premier le premier transparent
positionnant je dirais la donnant
explicitement la place de la recherche
au sein deacn donc la recherche fait
partie des missions de l'Institut et
étroitement lié aux activités
d'expertise comme C a été présenté par
Martial jurel lors de la première
session et elle apporte à cette
expertise d'une part des connaissances
des outils là il s'agit principalement
d'outils de simulation numérique et
enfin des compétences le budget annuel
que consacre l'Institut à la red en en
sûreté de l'ordre de 90 millions d'euros
et mobilise l'équivalent d'environ 280
personnes à pleint tempemps l'exposé
d'aujourd'hui sera limité au réacteur à
souspression secteur qui mobilise
l'essentiel de ce budget alors quelles
sont les caractéristiques majeures de
cette recherche en sûreté bien il s'agit
avant tout d'une recherche finalisée
structurée en projet et action dans le
cadre d'un d'un plan moyen long terme
intégrant dans une logique
programmatique l'ensemble des activités
de
l'Institut cette recherche fait par
ailleurs l'objet de d'évalu interne et
externe notamment avec le comité
d'orientation de la recherche de l'IRSN
son conseil que la ers qui nous permet
je dirais d'assurer une cohérence
d'ensemble et d'excellence scientifique